oh it's working now
holy mother
wow
uh
that's all i have to say to open this
segment up
i did not see this coming
joe biden
earlier was announced he was going to be
issuing some vaccine mandates
and that's him going back on his word
because he said last year it wasn't
going to happen we weren't going to do
passports we're going to do force
vaccination jen sackey said something
recently i think only a couple months
ago
and the word came out that joe biden was
going to implement some mandates well of
course
the rumor was he was going to mandate
federal employees and contractors to get
vaccinated that is massive because of so
many companies that contract with the
federal government they're going to
sever those contracts lay people off or
mandate vaccines
and
that's on par with what we've been
seeing from a lot of executives
mandating their employees get vaccinated
the one thing i did say in my earlier
segment was that joe biden does not have
the authority to mandate anything else
beyond that he can't just mandate
private businesses
uh mandate vaccines
uh mandate the mandate uh well joe biden
did because he is a psychopathic tyrant
and he is a crackpot authoritarian and
this is not this is no joke how bad this
is
i think
you know there are certain things you
can look back on in terms of egregious
executive decrees like japanese
internment camps
and
suspension of habeas corpus and things
like that this is definitely on par with
one of the most brazen things we've seen
from a president because it's not just
one thing joe biden has bypassed the
legislative branch on more than one
occasion with the eviction moratorium
then he then he violated the supreme
court
he violated the judicial branch and the
legislative branch by doing it again
the supreme court once again intervening
joe biden now has completely bypassed
the legislative branch by trying to
enact by decree
that businesses under a new osha rule
mandate vaccinations for everyone
for all their employees if they have at
least 100 employees
all right well i'll say this
we here at teamcast.com we do not have
more than 100 employees and um
it's hard to say whether or not we're
close to it
but
probably in the next year or so i
anticipated that we we would be around
there but i'll say it's regardless
i will not comply
do what you want say what you want it
ain't happening i got my van down by the
river if need be but i'm gonna stand up
i'm gonna say no and i'll ride this this
ship as long as as long as we can
there are a few there are a few moments
in this past couple of years that have
been genuinely shocking
one of the first because i've seen a lot
of things in my days traveling around
the world
one of the most shocking things i saw i
remember in the basement you know back
in march donald i think it was march
donald trump making a statement about
restricting travel to europe or i can't
remember exactly what was said and i was
like wow
like this is serious what's going on
with this covet stuff
what joe biden did today i did not
believe would happen i did not expect
and it is one of the most despotic
psychotic authoritarian things
we've ever seen
it is a thousand orders of magnitude
worse than anything trump ever did
we'll see if this
stands up to scrutiny but considering
that joe biden's already bypassed the
judicial branch and the legislative
branch on more than one occasion it
seems likely he's going to try and make
this stick
will it maybe not so maybe this is just
joe biden sabotaging any chance the
democrats are going to have in 2022 and
2024 because i tell you this you go to
rural people in swing states and tell
them we will say no to this and we will
end it and they're going to vote for you
without question they don't care what
your policies are you can tell them that
with all the taxpayer dollars we're
going to build a moon base made a cheese
to harvest moon cheese and they're going
to be like and you're going to shut down
this mandate stuff i'll vote for it
let's get into all this stuff let's
let's stop me from ranting it's just
it's that dark
joining us today is joey salads
thank you for having me pulling mike
down a little bit just point it at your
mouth
there you go yeah just talking to it
excellent
you got me wanting some of that moon
cheese now
what kind of cheese i have my munchies
bro that looks so good in that wallace
and grommets i know right what was there
really a grommet wall some ground skit
about moon cheese yeah there wasn't i'm
just saying you know people are gonna be
like this dude's lost the plot we got
anybody else this is gonna be a republic
what i i'll tell you if it's not a
republican sweep we're doomed and i
don't even like the republicans and i
don't even think the republicans can do
much but i'm talking about the insurgent
you know but anyway introduce yourself
joey who are you what are you doing um
i'm joey salads i go by joey saladino
now and uh yeah i've been doing youtube
for a pretty long time i guess i
partially retired from doing that now
i'm mostly just chilling handling
business and now i'm here right on man
thanks for coming on we got we got ian
hi thanks tim good to see you joe good
to see you always good to see you in
town man um well let's let's let's get
through these intros because i'm
freaking out about this
i'm a little bit concerned about this
and i'm curious hopefully we can come up
with something positive in this we'll
see
well before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member there is
going to be a members segment coming up
around 11 or so pm after the show we
record a segment just for the members of
the website and as a member you're
helping to support our fierce and
independent journalism we actually have
a report on the ground from new york
protest so definitely you don't want to
miss that stuff and as a member you get
an ad free experience but don't forget
to like this video subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends if there was anything to share
it is this story
you know what's really funny is is this
is so serious i'm even seeing reddit
kind of like you know go you know
you know reddit full of bots and
apologists for authoritarianism are like
ah this one's kind of crazy cause
the president doesn't have the
anyway
share the video let's let's let's let's
save it let's actually get into the news
here it is from the associated press
sweeping new vaccine mandates for 100
million americans the ap reports in his
most forceful pandemic actions and words
president joe biden on thursday
announced sweeping new federal vaccine
requirements affecting as many as 100
million americans in an all-out effort
to increase covet 19 vaccinations and
curb the surging delta variant
it's not just the new osha requirement
they say the expansive rules mandate
that all employers with more than 100
workers require them to be vaccinated or
test for the virus weekly affecting
about 80 million americans and the
roughly 17 million workers at health
facilities that receive federal medical
medicare and medicaid will also have to
be fully vaccinated there's also going
to be a requirement for all for all
employees of the executive branch
and contractors who do business with the
federal government but boy
if you watch this guy speak on tv
this was an iron fist moment he said
he's going to just i'll paraphrase here
but just push through any republican
governor who tries to oppose his
executive decree
we've got bread tube socialists
these these crackpot authoritarian
lunatics
cheering for rule by decree
true colors
shown mask slips off how about that when
we called him communists and they said
we're democratic socialists we just want
to vote for the power
and then once they vote for their guy
and he slams the gavel on the table and
says
you know we we we
it's like the emperor and star wars the
the the attempt to get to bypass the
senate
and congress
and they're cheering for it and so we
gotta we gotta we got a lot going on but
we should just definitely talk about
this the funny thing here i think is
that unions
are like whoa
whoa whoa you know we got it we got to
negotiate on this one
but i don't know guys is it any surprise
that uh
actually i think it is a surprise but
you know what are your thoughts on joe
biden just going full fascist
not really surprised at all
but it's crazy it's it's you're not
surprised come on
whatever the democrats want they've been
getting since day one especially when
cove had happened we never thought that
they would be locking us in our homes
for several months and they did exactly
that so yeah but that was under trump
right
when we had that that is true was the
democrat governor was the democrat
governors
trump republican yeah trump opposed it
but trump gave the rights to the state
which i was i was kind of on the fence
about having the states have those
rights to remove our constitutional
rights shouldn't that be the job of the
federal government to then step in and
preserve our constitutional rights
against democrat governor tyrants
but
well no no the federal government is
constantly trying to infringe on our
rights and we have this shield in the
constitution that is stopping them from
doing it but at this point it's like you
know joe biden with the with the
eviction moratorium
bypassed the legislative branch
supreme court said hey you can't do this
and he went i'll do it anyway thus
bypassing
the supreme court
and congress which is just basically the
executive has gone nuts with power and
he should be impeached immediately the
problem is
you know we're supposed to have this
mechanism in place to remove despots and
tyrants impeachment they try to impeach
trump over nothing
it's like he made a phone call and
they're like get rid of them
it's insane
yes and then and then january 6 is just
it's insane and now you actually have
a a aw and off the rails insane demented
psychopath
and you can't impeach him because the
democrats won't do it because they like
it they like the power they want it they
support it even if they do impeach him
it's not going to do any good because
then you just got kamala harris and it's
probably the same
tuple
then what who do you get next pelosi
impeacher too
then you get chuck grassley i would love
to do i would we got to kind of also be
realistic that's just it's just not
going to happen especially with the
democrats in charge it's you know i feel
like there's a lot of republican
representatives out there who are
pushing for impeachment i think taylor
green probably filed at least 12
different impeachments since she took
office eight months ago it's all just
fan service at this point all this
impeachment stuff and i forgot who said
it one of the republicans uh said it if
you want to impeach by it and focus on
the midterms so at the very least focus
on the midterms i really want to hire 70
people just so that we can have 100
workers and i can you know but we don't
have that many people here we have about
30 is there a loophole can you hire
people as independent contractors
i don't i don't know if that would count
uh
you know but i can just hire a hundred
hourly workers to you know move the lawn
with scissors
you could do that you could have 100
people that work from home in 100
different areas of the world and they're
going to be like that's more of a threat
that of people need to be vaccinated
than 30 people in a room together this
idiocy these blanket
decisions about numbers and people
aren't robots people this is this is one
of the biggest responses that i'm seeing
from a lot of people it's like wait a
minute we've got work from home we've
got covered mandates people are already
working remote
and now in your own home they're
mandating you be vaccinated that that
makes no sense that's that's really off
the road that's really it's nothing
about safety it's nothing about actually
keeping you safe it's all about they
just want to remove any unvaccinated
person from being able to function in
society to force you to get the vaccine
uh as much as possible without them
actually coming to your house and
jabbing yeah i gotta be honest i think
the actual goal here is just to uh
cause a u.s the u.s system the the us
government
to collapse completely it was happening
anyway the printing of money was
destroying our economy and this is
basically a i don't know if it's a mask
to do it but but whatever it's just
another reason it's outside of the money
thing what i'm talking about is we are
we are seeing unprecedented strain on
states on the federal government on
localities we are seeing shootouts you
know in in the pacific northwest
conflict in the streets
and there's no way
something this fascistic could pass
muster it's it's it's going to get i
mean it's they're going to get sued to
oblivion every republican state's going
to file a suit
republican states are going to start
telling all of their the companies
within their states
ignore this they can't do it
and then they're going to say we won't
we will not comply with the federal
government so what are you going to do
about it
this never could work this idea would
never happen there's no way west
virginia is going to be like well i
don't know biden said it there's no way
texas is going to be like
unfortunately we're beholden to
ron desantis so so what's the outcome of
this all it did is it's going to force
red states to make declarations against
the federal government in some capacity
whether it be sovereignty and we've seen
that in the past or a sanctuary decrees
or whatever it is just destroying the
bonds that keep this country together i
worry
that the federal government the way
they're going to probably try to enforce
this over businesses are they going to
start freezing people's bank accounts
removing the money from their account
and
i'm not like the biggest crypto guy or
i'm trying to promote crypto on to
people but i do feel like if
eventually society starts pushing to
this world of more you know crypto
having crypto wallets a crypto bank
account stuff that's decentralized off
the grid off the like you know if you
have a a bank account of with citibank
or whatever bank the government could
just step in and they'd done it to me
when i forgot to pay certain taxes and
they just take money out freeze the
account yep done like okay and they're
going to start doing we're going to see
that happen with companies that are
unvaccinated they're going to just take
your money
and one of the things we've always seen
throughout history is typically when
there's a big revolution that's brewing
or a civil resistance brewing it's
usually uh currency starts to split
it usually
you know we've seen it throughout
american history too i believe some
states had their own currencies at some
points and i mean i'm not trying to push
crypto on people but i feel like
cryptocurrency is kind of that push to
the new currency where let's just say
florida does secede from the union
if you're on the us dollar the federal
government can just screw with florida
beyond belief but if it's all in bitcoin
that's why they get this why they hate
bitcoin it's an escape yeah it's a way
out of their system
fourteen thousand dollars per violation
for it it's the osha rule
if they they say you have to get uh uh
vaccinated or a weekly test i think it's
really funny because i tweeted i will
not comply and the response from
everybody was you don't even have 100
employees you're exempt and i'm like yo
i'm not i'm saying in general dude
they're getting they're going insane
with this stuff
we'll we'll have 100 employees but by
this time next year or maybe we won't
maybe all that happens now
is companies start saying
instead of just hiring everybody under
one company we make a new company that
does a different job oh you got a a
media production company well your
graphic design should just be under a
new company called magic graphic design
and you contract them yeah all of a
sudden you've breaking your according to
this rule you can have a thousand people
in the same building with ten thousand
companies uh or
a thousand companies and that's way
safer than having a hundred people
spread across the world under one
company they're according to this
there would at some point be the irs
being like hey this is kind of messed up
you can't do if there were a thousand
people each owned their own company all
working together in one room
that's a lot more viral load than a
hundred employees in one company across
the world working from home this is the
thing is what you just said what you
would what you would do in a month or
two months from now if you did end up
doing that if that was a thing people
said they'll just rewrite it rewrite the
bill rewrite the law
so if you as an individual are paying
people or you as an individual own
several companies that a master you know
they can't do that they'll do it that's
the democrats they definitely wouldn't
do that because that would that would
destroy all of their big donors
so when they're saying vaccine mandate
you think pepsi cares but going in and
then saying we are now going to start
administering businesses based on the
individual involved they'd be like whoa
well we got shell company after shell
company something in panama something in
bahamas nah none of that there's another
interesting thing though a lot of people
may have missed this one because it
wasn't big news but uh there was an
alert put out by this um community
banking association this group that the
irs wants
they they want any transaction six
hundred dollars uh or more to be tracked
by the banks it used to be i think like
ten thousand
or what might have been like six
thousand or something six hundred now
any deposit not withdrawals anything wow
anything anytime you pull money out
anything that's nuts anytime you check
your account
i said over six hundred dollars okay
okay anytime money gets moved yes over
600 they want to be able to trade if you
move it from a savings account to your
own checking yes wow that's an account
transfer wow
yup i don't think people realize how bad
it's about to get
and i think we're we're not long for
youtube i think you know that time is
coming
i think a lot of big channels are look
the faster they implement these things
the faster they implement these things
i mean look it was it was december when
joe biden said no mandatory vaccinations
it was july i think when sachi said we
don't think the vaccine should be
mandatory
now look where we're at now we have
delta version which is less deadly but
more transmissible from what i've
learned the double we have lambda
epsilon and mu and he's doing a vaccine
this is a vaccine mandate for the delta
variant according to this article but
firstly from what i know no vaccines are
made for the delta variant that are out
yet it's not even about it's not about
safety like i get what you're saying
you're right you're probably right about
almost everything that you're saying
about you know people in a building
vaccines for it's not even none of that
even matters it's not even about that
when it comes to the what these democrat
lawmakers are
what they're mandating and deciding has
not it has nothing worse
in science at all no we're so we're so
far beyond
acting like what the the the democrats
the government and the neocons the
republican establishment it's we're so
far beyond think that them acting in
accordance to norms and laws and what we
expect
they are just operating with impunity
that's it
now to be fair the republican
establishment is basically just a
pressure release valve for america for
americans so when a bunch of americans
are getting fed up and angry with this
bag i'm going to vote republican
and the republicans will be like we're
going to push back on this and then
lindsey graham will walk over and high
five kamala congratulations welcome to
the country party another thing i don't
like to see and it's coming from greg
abbott desantis and a lot of alcohol i
guess emotional conservatives on the
internet
and they're seeing what the left is
doing the democrats are doing they're
mandating vaccines they're using the arm
of the federal government or their state
governments to demand everybody get a
vaccine but then i'm watching the
inverse happen
as a reaction to that and we're seeing a
lot of conservatives
saying let's mandate no vaccine like
businesses can't mandate vaccines at all
and i'm watching this inverse of i guess
fascism occurring where it's like two
sides of this fascist coin going on
and they're both being cheered by their
own side and i think that's that's could
be something that's going to be
dangerous counter dependence i disagree
when the republicans say you as a
business can't mandate vaccines
i think that's a broad
non-discriminatory policy we have tons
of policies affecting businesses about
who they can't discriminate against
so
yeah but that's that's quite simple
that's the thing is
if you're for for instance in texas in
austin texas there were two restaurants
that were requiring their customers to
have vaccines
and i guess they were operating fine the
government of texas came in and said
we're going to pull your liquor license
if you keep requiring this right so i'm
assuming they probably stopped requiring
it now they're going to do all the
lawsuits
that was two restaurants an entire state
or city that had no type of vaccine
mandate and i'm watching the businesses
did the businesses and it was right of
the government to shut down that and
discriminated and the government was
shutting it down i guess for
discrimination good but where i come in
saying is i believe that should be up to
the free market to decide if a business
that requires vaccine should be able to
survive or not let's just say you're an
old person let's just say you're high
high risk let's say you're a crazy
leftist living in your little bubble
inside your house with a mask with
several vaccines in your arms and you
want to go outside and you live in texas
and you're seeing all these rising
numbers of covet cases you're seeing all
these deaths and you want to go
somewhere where you feel safe
should they have a right to patron a
business
that requires vaccines do you think the
government should have uh
stepped in to enforce desegregation at
private businesses
i don't think my opinion when it comes
to a lot of this stuff i would say when
it comes to segregation maybe around
color
that's a different
area because i mean obviously you can't
change anything about your your personal
your physical appearance but
what always gets me when it comes to the
health reason it's like obviously you
have a choice whether you get vaccinated
or not and
it's also
that ideology you kind of gotta adjust
it where there's a lot of conservatives
saying they shouldn't be able to
discriminate against your health they
shouldn't be able to discriminate
against if you're vaccinated or not but
at the same time if you use i i don't
like to uh strawman but i think it's
important to hold that belief uh
constant in a bunch of different
situations say someone was showing up to
your restaurant and they had visible
leprosy
their skin peeling off the bone and
they're trying to get in you can't
discriminate against me because of my
health
let me in well you're going to get
everybody sick if you come in your
skin's falling off the bone that's what
the judiciary is for
so
if we say like look there's got to be
some limits on public health and safety
and there's there's areas where you can
discriminate
whether or not someone is vaccinated or
unvaccinated is
between their doctors and if the
vaccines provide protection for the
individual then you shouldn't be worried
about what other people aren't doing the
issue here is that well another thing
how the vaccine's working i'm at i'm
anti-vaccine mandates there there is a
herd immunity situation that does come
in that makes vaccines work here's the
issue what the democrats and what biden
want is for everyone to be vaccinated
because they're like that's how we
return to normal everyone has to do it
it's not about the individual it's about
the entirety and the the excuses they
make online is like but it's
unvaccinated people who are in the
hospitals and it's like well then that's
their problem
maybe they should go to a doctor and
talk about this and maybe they wouldn't
be in the hospital if they had some good
medical advice how about that how about
it's none of your business what they
decide to do here's the problem
with the vaccine mandates
some places like new york no medical
exemptions none
for no reason so if you're someone who's
got a disability or some some existing
condition and you can't get vaccinated
you're out
this mandate from joe biden it's gonna
force people to get coveted tests every
single week this is this is putting a
mandate that's gonna put undue pressure
you got businesses finding people
charging them money
now let's say you have no clean
exemption but
the fda says
that right now data on pregnancy is
insufficient to inform someone on the
risks this is the community vaccine they
say pregnant uh data on pregnancy is
insufficient to inform on the risk they
don't know
and the the fda approval says
that there is no long-term data on the
community vaccine because they've just
entered those late stage trials and that
will be coming later on
so if you are someone who talks to your
doctor and maybe you have a history of
anaphylaxis maybe you've had uh
gilan bahre syndrome in the past and
your doctor says well you know to be
honest
i think you should get it i won't bar
you from getting it but that's going to
be up to you
and then you as an individual have to
weigh the probabilities of whether or
not you will take the risk for this
reason pregnancy is a big one because
the the i believe it's the cdc said it
is safe for pregnant women to take the
vaccine
however the fda for the fda approved
community says that data is insufficient
to inform on the risks but they think
it's safe right basically they have no
data and they're assuming it's safe so
if you're applying a woman you might be
like
i'm not comfortable with that too bad no
exception that's it now now these
businesses if they start doing it one by
one they're discriminating against
people i understand your point that it's
like two small businesses yeah i'm
saying that's the thing is when it comes
into that situation there's a free
market that decides where if there is
let's just say in this hypothetical
world
you're in a town there's no mandates at
all when it comes to anything vaccine
and all these businesses are starting to
require vaccine mandates to enter every
single business
and then let's say you have a large swap
of that population that is not
vaccinated
in the market of supply and demand
there's going to be businesses that are
going to appeal and you know
be created or be adjusted for the people
who are unvaccinated because there's a
large market share of people who
need to patron businesses and they don't
have businesses to patron so that's why
i believe the free market is that
sorts that stuff out
it didn't
the reason why with the government had
to
physically enforce desegregation
is that the free market was not figuring
it out is that it was actually
people had no incentive to change there
was this famous story about i think it
was lyndon johnson and he had uh several
black men who worked for him and they
would drive his car and his dog down i
think it was texas or whatever i
remember the exact details or they would
drive his car and then one one time he
asked him can you bring my dog with you
and they were like no
it's hard enough to find anywhere to go
to get service let alone having a dog
with us would be impossible and he was
like what do you mean why and they're
like yo driving through the south
there's no businesses for people based
on your race like it's all the free
market wasn't solving for that it was
creating serious problems i think race
is a
different situation just because
especially when you're dealing with
stuff back then i mean if there was any
segregated places nowadays like no black
people we do have segregated businesses
now if you think about it there's all
these
la super you know tech companies popping
up where they specifically don't hire
white males you know we have all these
dating websites specifically for jews
specifically for minorities specifically
for this and
no one bats and i really no one really
cares okay that's a business for that
type of person business for these types
of people especially as you enter the
tech age
you can kind of target people based on
what your needs are
but i guess from the point where i'm
coming from is
in texas where there was no mandates at
all no mandates in either direction
there was only two restaurants that
really popped up requiring vaccines
austin probably in austin yeah and i bet
you they were probably getting business
i could assume because if they're the
only two in that market share and let's
just say there's 50 percent of the
population there that is vaccinated they
might be seeking vaccinated places
and i believe it should be there right
if they're scared sick old or dying to
be able to go to a place where they can
feel safe i think all of this if you
don't want to go somewhere else i think
all of this regardless i think joe
biden's
psychotic behavior
his his inability to speak
his handlers whatever and his decree
let me show you what's happening
biden vows to take on gop governors over
schools yeah he didn't just say that he
says get them out of the way right now
local school officials are trying to
keep children safe
in a pandemic while the governor picks a
fight with them and even threatens their
salaries or their jobs talk about
bullying in schools biden said remarks
the white house if they'll not help if
these governors won't help us beat the
pandemic i'll use my power as president
to get them out of the way
i think i think there's like a ninth and
a tenth amendment about that one that
you can't do that joe biden i think i
think it was a few weeks ago uh the
buying administration said that they
were going to fund the schools that get
defunded over masked mandates so
desantis was saying we're going to
defund these schools because
uh you're requiring masks that's no good
and then i think the administration said
they were going to work to fund those
schools whatever was defunded
governor christie gnome said south
dakota will stand up to defend freedom
joe biden see you in court
all joe biden did with these decrees
was
he it was it was a shot across the bow
to red states
forcing them to assert their positions
in defiance of the federal government
these mandates these threats getting
them out of the way all that stuff
it's it's absurd it's not going to
happen the feds are not going to be able
to go into texas and start going
business to business knocking on doors
and trying to figure things out now
there's taxes
that's where they might get you with the
irs and the currency that's all it comes
down to at the end of the day they can't
they don't have the manpower really and
they wouldn't be able to logistically go
to every single business every door but
what they can do is click a few buttons
on the computer and lock all your bank
accounts i think that's what it pretty
much comes down to we're pretty much
controlled by the us dollar at the end
of the day that's where they have all
that power and all that control over us
because they can click two or three
buttons shut everything but yeah you
know it's in fascism yeah do you think
that people in texas south dakota are
gonna be like oh no i guess i have to
comply with joe biden
you got wyoming and west virginia the
deepest trump supporting states in the
country you think these places are going
to be like oh geez i guess i have to
comply or do you think they'll be like
screw you yeah they're going to say
screw you and then their bank accounts
are going to get frozen and then they'll
there'll be like a state
issue with the governor whatever is
going to be like to the local you know
local banks that are only in these
certain areas undo it you can't do that
yeah governors will intervene and then
the federal government will probably try
to hit those banks and shut those local
banks down you know
there's always that like who's got the
bigger you know hammer when it comes to
that situation who's got more control
over the powers the businesses will
switch to crypto yeah florida will work
up their own crypto and then the federal
government will make that crypto illegal
probably a felony and then they'll start
they'll withhold tax money to the state
and then you might see other states join
in and you could see definitely maybe
not civil war but intense civil conflict
dude we're innocent yeah political
but we'll start with uh
i assume first generational warfare is
like two people punching each other in
the face and likes you know charging at
each other but in order to gain control
of resources or influence over a city or
a region or a group of people
you can't convince them it goes into
kinetic conflict right physical
confrontation
there's been multiple generations
there's been espionage there's been
cyber warfare we are moving into the era
now beyond all that which is fourth and
fifth generation warfare fourth
generational warfare is when when it's
not necessarily nation states anymore
it's um
people flying different banners within
states and between states insurgent
groups groups like the taliban groups
like al qaeda and groups like
antifa fifth generation warfare is more
in
winning control of resources by
controlling people's minds through
propaganda and information
so in that regard
no no doubt the culture war they call it
right it's been called a cold civil war
over and over again the problem i have
with that phrase cold is that i don't
know there was a dude in portland took
two boats to the chest
by a guy who was stalking him and had a
had a communist tattoo on his neck seems
hot yeah you've got oh it's limited
those are the you'll see limited pockets
of violence and like even the civil war
i mean there was korea or not the civil
war rather the cold war with russia we
had korea which was like a russian
american conflict but in the proxy of a
guy getting sort of but that's like
communist factions supported by a larger
state versus
free enterprise faction supported by
another state that wasn't the us
engaging in direct conflict yeah
indirect that's why they call it the
cold war it was a war but it was proxy
now what we're seeing in the united
states isn't cold civil war when you
have people fighting in the streets and
there was a shootout last weekend and
there was a shootout the weekend before
that like how about a hundred days of
violent rioting in portland with fire
bombs
and then when donald trump is like we're
sending some feds together like oh
fascist fascists like dude you're
firebombing buildings and then you had
the oregon governor i think it was the
a.g sue the federal government over
their attempts to enforce the law now
you get the democrats in the federal
government they're going nuts and now
it's the the so here's what i said when
the blue state was suing you know donald
trump uh the federal government over
trying to enforce the law and stop the
uh the fire bombings the riots
i was like
this is it
people live in
you know they they view history through
a can through condensed lenses
where you open a book and you read about
the civil war and it's like on this day
this happened on this day this happened
and this day this happened and you're
like wow and you're reading it all
really fast not realizing for the people
living it
yo it was years
like five years the revolutionary war
was 20 years
there were people who were born after
the first conflict in the american
revolution and and
rebel sentiment and then fought in the
war
for two years they were born into it
this stuff went on for a really really
really long time i also feel like uh the
transfer of information back then did
definitely took a lot longer than
nowadays right and that's why
it's accelerated now i mean you wanted
to draft a letter it takes you know a
month to have these meetings where they
finally grin the letter then it takes
three months to get to the crown then
the king finally gets a chance to go
through the letter reads it crafts a
response with his advisors and goes to
parliament takes a month three months
later it comes back to the states and
then doesn't even go to every single
state yeah you know so that that could
have taken a year just to have one
message now it's all different but
here's what happens
oregon sues the federal government i
said this is it i mean the federal the
state is rejecting federal authority to
enforce the law on federal property in
their state this is where it begins
now joe biden is trying to enforce
federal decree on red states and they're
going to be doing the same things yo
i love it when people are like i was
talking to russell brand i was on i did
the russell brand podcast recently
and he he brought up he's like you know
you've talked quite a bit about civil
war in the past and i was like yeah
that's true and i was like there's a lot
of things you need to understand about
that for one i was right okay and uh we
just had a shootout last weekend and the
weekend before that and you might say oh
but those are just shootouts
when did we have shootouts five years
ago this is what's up it wasn't
happening but let's break this down i
was like
we had numerous articles from the
atlantic and all these other smart
people about the possibility of a civil
war escalating in the united states
especially with donald trump getting
elected you then had a princeton
professor saying i think this is in 2016
we are in a cold civil war this was a
long time ago
and that sentiment emerges and then we
see the battle for berkeley the base
stick man
old women getting explosives thrown at
him i was watching this stuff happen on
the ground in in san jose and berkeley
at these trump rallies and then i was
like yo people have lost their minds
you don't see a de-escalation when
people want to tit for tat
so i was like i think we're going to see
a civil war and it's not always the
like when you saw those people uh
assault larry elder those are obviously
like l.a crackheads that are just
radical crackheads just roaming the
streets probably don't leave yeah but
they have access to political
information yeah being indoctrinated yes
what i'm saying is at that berkeley one
i think you were there and i was there
at the same time i noticed
an older crowd
who looked normal they looked like they
could have been teachers waving little
trump flags no no not not that they were
picking up rocks they were on the antifa
side they were picking up rocks and
throwing them at trump supporters and i
saw them there and i was undercover
because i wanted to you know capture
what was going on i told him like hey
guys i'm like you might want to get out
of here this is like nasty because they
would just look like regular people that
just probably walked down the wrong
street and recording it and then i
looked back at the tape and they were
picking up rocks and throwing it at the
trump supporters so where where was
surprise where did we end up right to
have people come to me and and you know
i love these these you know bread tubers
and leftists being like ah tim pool
think civil war and i'm like well since
those predictions which i've continued
to make we had january 6 where about a
thousand people stormed into the capitol
building well i should say a large
number of them stormed to the front
gates and
a lot of people were escorted in by cops
opening the door but they did disrupt
the electoral college vote count now a
lot of trump supporters think that it
was effectively a setup in that police
were standing down that pelosi didn't
get you know uh national guard in there
regardless people fought with cops to
get into the capitol building they had
no real plan that's what the fbi report
says but they did shut down the
electoral college vote i'm not here to
overplay this and call an insurrection
i'm saying
yo that's unprecedented and what did we
see around the same time we had i think
it was 48 states involved in a lawsuit
over how the election was handled and
i'm sitting here like yo
i've been telling you people shooting
each other in the streets a dude being
killed then then trump having feds hunt
down the guy who did it and kill him
like yo we are dangerously close to this
stuff falling apart john podesta as
reported by the boston globe said that
if trump wins in 2020 the west coast
should secede from the union a new ugov
poll data showing that in the united
states five different regions
37.2 percent of the american population
wants their region to secede from the
union a lawsuit between 48 states
contesting the election and to this day
what 80 million or i think it's like
two-thirds of republicans distrusting
the election results
how are you going to come to tell me
we had people on this show
we wrapped up one show and one dude who
came on was like no i think everything's
going to go back to normal everything's
fine and i was like what what part of
people shooting each other beating each
other in the streets
massive lawsuits between states quantum
computing neural net fusion what what's
there's no no
i'm talking about everything's changing
what part of the active conflict makes
you think things will stop has joe biden
come out and said i want to be a good
president to everyone in this country
and knowing that there are 80 million
americans who are skeptical and hesitant
to vaccines i want to have a
conversation with you and work with you
that's why i'm going to be announcing
you know a new plan to work with
republican leaders and have discussions
over protecting civil liberties no he
doesn't do that he says
he what did he say
we've been patient but our patience is
wearing thin power like who's he talking
about that's right he i mentioned this
before when he came out when texas and
florida announced that they were
shutting they're like we're not going to
do these shutdowns we're not going to
have these mandates he came out and said
we may need more restrictions we may
need more mass mandates and that was an
important point earlier this year i said
who was he talking to
he wasn't talking to texas he wasn't
talking to south dakota south dakota
never shut down he wasn't talking to
florida no he was talking only to blue
states joe biden is the president who
comes out on tv and says us and we
against you you know he just he just
pulled off the biggest in my opinion
military blunder in american history he
he surrendered to the taliban after a
20-year war that we had control we were
in control and had
china i think more than anybody else
devastated not only the way we look in
the world who would trust us to ally
with us if we're going to walk away and
leave them to die afterwards if we're
looking at who benefits the most from
everything that biden's doing i don't
have to say probably china's benefiting
the most so he's saving face this is him
coming out hard out of the closet to be
angry to take the immediately i'm like
what is he talking about anything other
than afghanistan for right now he's he
wants to focus on how cool he how strong
he is this is
totally this total power play another
thing i agree
this policy doesn't fly it's going to
get sued into oblivion he'll probably
try and bypass the supreme court anyway
but boy did it change the conversation
afghanistan we're talking about this
instead of afghanistan now yeah another
thing is like i i wonder because i know
you were saying that they kind of want
the states to split in a way where like
florida is its own state i wonder how
that's going to go because i know in new
york city i'll just use this as a
smaller scale example my hometown staten
island
it's technically part of new york city
it pays new york city taxes pays new
york state taxes but everyone in staten
island for the most part it's the only
republican borough
out of the entirety of new york city
it's not even it's not anything like
anything else in new york city
geographically and the people
but they refuse to let staten island
secede from new york city they just
refuse
i believe it's because they don't want
a part of new york that's not adherent
to the new york city tax code
and just have everybody from new york
city just living over there in staten
island because what would happen is
tons of businesses will just okay we're
just going to go right over the bridge
we're going to we're going to just move
right over the bridge and manhattan
would just lose tons of business
new york city tax i think is like 3.5
percent 3.5 just and there's no reason
for staten island to be paying that
because we're nothing like the rest of
the city it's just a completely
different world it might as well just be
new jersey at that point yeah and i i
feel like that's going to be the same
exact thing when it comes to florida and
texas if they want to secede if florida
and texas ever did get out of there
they're either going to have to one try
to destroy the economy of that of those
states as much as possible so this way
no one would ever want to live there or
they would have to force them to stay
because they don't want it to become a
beacon of freedom where zero percent
taxes every business just come here
you've got no federal government
breathing down your neck you wanna have
your trillion dollar business here you
wanna have your small business here yeah
just come here no one's gonna bother you
just come here and do whatever you want
and check it out right now there's a lot
going on with these vaccine mandates
truckers
if the truckers of the united states
right now said i'm good
strike
whole country shuts down everything
everything shuts down they have all the
power people don't realize when you when
you zoom out on america you look at
america on the satellite map you look at
it in real time i'm not saying you
actually have access to do that but
let's say you could you know what you
see on the roads you see on all the
highways they look like veins and you
know what those trucks are those are the
red blood cells carrying the oxygen to
all of the major centers to make sure
that people can survive how does it work
with amazon do they own their own truck
drivers oh dude
so in rural areas when you order from
amazon it comes it gets delivered to a
post office and then it either come or
actually when we order on amazon
we get ups fedex and post and postal
deliveries for amazon stuff
when in in the cities there's an amazon
warehouse and they hire their own
drivers and the person will show up put
it in their car drive it to you not here
we get that sometimes but typically it
has to be delivered through it's still
got to go from the production center and
the warehouse to these distribution
centers either way so it's got to come
from a big truck then their little
drivers can handle it well here's here's
the important point
let's say you live in texas no vaccine
mandates
they're like we got we got a shipment
it's going out to new york can't do it
yeah because if i go there i'm not going
to be able to eat any food or go to
restaurants i'm not going to do it i'm
not going to be able to go into the gas
station sorry
actually not even going to be able to go
into the the the warehouse to drop it
off
now there may be some exceptions like oh
you're just dropping something off fine
you're getting take out new york says
it's fine there's probably reasons why
they did this
but how many of these truck drivers are
going to be like and not worth the risk
i'm not going to drive all that way for
this job and then find out that i can't
even interact the other way is different
new york will be able to go to texas
vaccinated new york truck drivers will
have no problem going to texas so it's
all going to start flowing towards these
rights the thing is these cities are the
ones that really need these imported
supplies and goods too
yeah i
i think um
you know i don't know exactly how this
plays out
you know i've said for a long time civil
war we were just talking about that but
i do think based on that yougov data
about it's 37.2 percent of people want
their region to break apart from the
united states or i'm sorry yeah yeah
each different
region has a different population size
but overall in the united states there's
a 37.2 percent of people want their
region to break apart
i look at that and i'm like maybe it's
just balkanization
maybe that's not even the right word for
it because you know you talk about like
the balkan wars and stuff and
you know the balkanization that happened
maybe what we're going to see is a
little bit different and it's more going
to be just a disillusion of the union
decentralization of the union the states
become the states and take care of their
own business and that's it i think we've
been in maybe not a civil war but with
first of all the federal reserve really
those guys really wanted to take control
of the american economy which they kind
of did then the soviets we had the
communist
american conflict so then we had the
chinese which we still have so it's like
we've been in this conflict
for for 100 years and it's it's evolved
and morphed into a different shape where
it's like me and you and you we all
these different opinions now your
neighbors aren't the people that you
relate to them and so there's all this
psychological conflict that's being sewn
and i hate seeing americans versus
americans on this i don't think that's
the prob what it is we got divided over
the last 15 years really really sadly
unnecessarily
it's it's more than just an american
problem it's a global problem and i
think we really need to be unified you
know closer and closer to what's
happening in australia that's where
we're going
i'm sorry yeah i got to just i got to
disagree with you you you you constantly
you know want to like you hold this
belief of like we shouldn't be divided
people should come together but i think
you missed the boat on that one a long
time ago i can't stop though i can't
stop myself i i get it but look two
different these are the things i was
talking about in 2016 yeah i was like 20
2007 hey guys we should we shouldn't be
hyper polarizing like this we can't just
be pointing the fingers 2018 i'm like yo
this fighting's got to stop people i
actually said people should stop showing
up to these things to just simmer down i
understand people want to go out and
protest they have a right to do it but
all it's going to do is create a
tit-for-tat so why don't people just
chill out right now now we're at the
point there is no turning back you got
people like hassan [ __ ] one of the
biggest if not the biggest independent
political commentator cheering for
nationwide rule by decree cheering for
it mocking those as as you have someone
abide in an office violating like
overtly violating the constitution the
law over overruling legislation supreme
court on multiple occasions and he's
cheering for it while at the same time
you have some of these same people
saying
the abortion law in texas is wrong the
government you know my body my choice
oh but this is contagious we shouldn't
allow it we shouldn't allow the virus to
kill people
but we should be allowed to abort babies
the see there's no there's no logical
consistency other than give me the power
to enact the things i want there is no
reconciling that ian when these people
by like 54 believe the economy is doing
good right now
there's i'm sorry man
they come out and they claim that every
trump supporter is ingesting horse pace
which is just not true it's a small they
did the same thing with the trump and
the bleach situation right right it's
first of all trump said something dumb
and they act like people actually
believe that stuff but i'll tell you
this the reality
independent voters and republican voters
are not running around in ingesting
horse pace it's just not happening some
some people are and it's a stupid thing
is the guy that they're making fun of
joe rogan ended up getting better in
like three days but he went to a doctor
and the doctor gave him a prescription
he got monoclonal antibodies which is an
fda authorized treatment and that's
probably what did it yeah but here's the
point we we can say definitively yeah we
know there are dumb people going to
tractor supply you go to tractor supply
there's horse pace missing because
people bought it but they only had like
30 boxes anyway so there's not tens of
millions of crackpots you look at the
republicans right now the republicans in
the polls
a large portion do not like the
republican party because they're paying
attention independent voters think the
economy is bad don't like the
republicans or the democrats
the metric
democrats believing the economy is good
is proof these people live in wally
world evidence evidence it's not proof
but it's there's only like three
thousand people though that that i think
that study it was only like three
thousand uh that showed the democrats
thought the economy was good no it's
like a hundred thousand is it i thought
that was a different study oh no no it's
like a hundred they're still only maybe
they think it's good because they're
getting their checks in the mail right
no it's because joe biden got elected
and also there's a spike in people
believing the economy you're gonna get a
hundred thousand morons in any political
here's the other thing i guess when it
comes to the ubi and all these checks
that everyone's been getting
i guess andrew yang and the whole i
guess ubi socialist crowd are saying we
need this money we need this money we'll
be productive we'll go to good it'll
help us do this help us do that and what
happens when the a lot of these people
get their money louis vuitton stocks
skyrockets you know
because they're going to buying gucci
bags
purses whatever they're doing i live in
vegas now and i've been flying back and
forth and what i noticed is probably 75
percent of the flights have been
extremely ghetto
extremely rowdy no flight etiquette i'm
getting i mean have you seen these
videos people fighting and boxing on
planes they're coming on the planes and
they got boom boxes and they're blasting
music they're cursing at the flight
attendants they're yelling at the pilots
oh we're gonna have a 10-minute delay
landing a little bit busy today you're
lying to us you're f in lionel wise get
us off freaking out and this is like 75
percent of the fights i've been going on
lately in and out of vegas have been
like that also i talked to a lot of
people on the strip a lot of security
they said at the time when i was talking
they said crime has been going up on the
strip and i asked why i came to the
conclusion i think this might be true
that because the airlines and uh the
casinos are all giving these deals to
get people back into the city and people
are all having these checks come in the
mail that never earned it and they just
want to go blow it and they're getting
you know less desirable people coming
into town starting problems starting
crime i even when i was in the casino uh
not too long ago i had i think three
people try to start a fight with me one
person tried to start a fight with me
because i asked if i liked alex jones
and they tried to start a fight with me
they asked you yeah they asked me
because i was having a political
conversation with my friend's mom and
they turned around they're like you like
alex jones i'm like i think he's cool
he's definitely entertaining well you're
uh and he just called me you know one of
these words that i can't not
no not not he definitely called you a
slur yeah
[Music]
things like youtube bands us for yeah i
was like dude just go just go away from
me and then like literally i go to
another table and someone like yells
joe because the guy next to me his name
was joe he wasn't with me and i like
glanced back and i looked back he's like
and i wasn't effing talking to you and
he starts to try to size me up i'm like
bro get out of here like what are you
doing i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
point something out to you ian that i
think is really really important
right now
you talk about you know you want unity
and how we can't have this polarization
it's not the people we got to blame
somebody else
you have high profile verified influence
influential personalities with you know
millions of followers
who are cheering
for the complete destruction of the
american form of government that we have
a checks and balance that that we have
checks and balances that we have an
executive a legislative and
judicial branch all equally powerful
calling each other out when they break
when they when they step out of the line
right now you have many people i mean
just go on twitter you can see them all
these are the people on the left in the
establishment
celebrating that what joe celebrating
what joe biden did on numerous occasions
bypassing the american way of government
these people are acting against the
american way of government
let me explain something
when barack obama you know he wants to
do daca right deferred action for
childhood rivals i think it's what it
means
there's a question over
well
the president can give orders to the
executive branch and how they handle
certain cases so there's a legal
question there
if you and a lot of people argue this is
legislation obama should not be able to
do this and then others argued well he
can simply tell ice not to enforce it
because he can instruct them to do it
and that's that's well that's exactly
executive branch then you've got to get
lawsuits lawsuits got to get involved
when donald trump wants to have a travel
ban based on you know this list of
countries of of threats
some argue
well that's got to go through
legislation yeah but
it's also that the the the president has
the ability to declare emergencies and
take executive action that's the point
of the executive branch
what joe biden did today
mandating that businesses with a hundred
employees or more be fined fourteen
thousand dollars if they don't get
weekly tests or verify vaccination is
overtly a legislation thing when joe
biden bypassed a supreme court ruling by
enacting a new eviction moratorium he
directly spat in the face of the supreme
court violating in no uncertain terms
the checks and balances of this country
and now you have people on the left
celebrating this
how do we move forward as a country when
half of the political population because
not every person in america is
celebrating the collapse of the american
way of governance
it's like the left's ideology i say this
all the time on my show
basically the same way you just said it
too is their their ideology is just a
sliding scale where they can go from we
need to support abortion right to murder
babies in the womb that's my right it's
like the only time they care about their
constitutional right is when it comes to
murdering and aborting babies um but
when it comes to forcefully getting
vaccinated being locked in the house all
this all that that comes with it uh for
the public health and public safety all
of a sudden the constitution doesn't
exist your rights don't exist but it's
it's just like there's they have well
their whole entire ideology is a sliding
scale with no consistencies and about
what benefits them at that moment at
that time but it's also
you know i i think you'll understand
this ian
we cannot be a a a civilization of
people
fighting for 100 safety
it's impossible
but that seems to be what the left right
now is saying
sacrifice everything for more safety we
saw in the colleges when they created
the safe spaces if a lecturer says a
naughty word and you're offended here's
a pastel room full of stuffed animals
and bean bags for you to go crying
those are real things oh big tech
companies had safe spaces for when trump
won the election that's like oh they
were crying yeah so these are people who
are voting and enforcing safety safety
safety above all after january 6th i i
know a bunch of people that work for
companies and their companies had uh
mental health days after the january 6th
remember that yeah a lot of a lot of
that and they still have mental health
days whenever something big happens in
the news
which is utterly pathetic in my book but
we're we're watching this happen
that safety has become paramount over
everything else and what did ben
franklin say those that would sacrifice
freedom for for temporary security
deserve neither and will lose both and
here's the thing is us republicans or
people on the right
we don't care what
people on the left do like me personally
i would rather us just kind of split you
live your life let me live my life but
it's they can't let that happen
they want to force us to live by the
rules that they want
them to live by
it's like they can't just say hey can we
just all just throw ourselves in florida
just leave us alone like we'll all just
stay in these states stop telling us
what to do just leave us alone we won't
bother you you won't bother us
but they know and i think when it comes
down to a lot of like the truck drivers
and the unions they kind of need us for
that and california is always like oh we
have the biggest economy in the state
well listen what's the comedy in the
world but why what does it mean best why
would anyone give up their serfs
yeah you know so you've got eastern
oregon wanting to secede from the state
it's like we don't need animals why
would why would portland
allow their serfs who pay taxes to to
leave the state
no i don't know we need those resources
we need that access to leverage us yeah
but but you've seen it right
i mean the constant drive towards safety
we can't do that we can't live that way
people think
seems that people think this that the
covet is is deadly like smallpox or like
or like uh polio like it's like it's a
debilitating crippling disease it's not
good for you and it definitely seems to
have detrimental effects but to act like
it's like it's as dangerous as polio i i
get it suspend habeas corpus if there's
a life-threatening devastating virus
that's causing people to fall down their
arms are rotting off they're bleeding
out of their face
you call you call up off you call off
habeas corpus and you
you heal the people with whatever you
have but that's not what we saw we saw
uh uh uh
incredibly transmissible disease that's
what is it 99.4
of the people that get it i think come
out of it okay i think that's the number
is that people who tested or people who
actually these of cases of confirmation
99 over 99 of the people are coming out
okay and now the cdc has said twice as
many people have been infected as per
previously that'd be 99.5 percent of it
well it it it doesn't change i was i was
reading about this it doesn't change
case fatality but the point is
a lot it means a lot of people have
gotten this didn't realize it
and i'll tell you this you know we've
had people on the show and when you
actually have someone explain to you
like what getting coveted was like you
really don't want to get it i've had the
flu
and the flu was it was a nightmare i
lost 20 pounds overnight i was shaking i
was pale i used to kill people oh yeah i
thought back then you knew you had the
flu you knew you were gonna be fine i i
had no no no no no no no you thought you
were actually gonna dude i lost 20
pounds overnight i was like i need to go
to the hospital i'll say well here's me
but here's the point but here's the
point i wanted to make that when it
comes to covid you hear about you know
we had someone on the show explaining
how all of a sudden one day he couldn't
breathe anymore he couldn't have a
conversation he's like i gotta go to the
hospital we had john pierce on the show
and then a month later he's in the
hospital because like so so that's
that's something to consider it is it is
more it is i think it's twice as deadly
or it's
more deadly than the flu we're dealing
with something different now with the
variance they're more infectious there's
long-term effects
they're not as deadly i don't have the
full numbers to pull up but i think
here's where we need to be
covet is scary long-term health effects
for younger people are bad mortality
tends to be for older people there's
some promising studies on therapeutics
and alternative treatments there's some
vaccines hey how about we be honest
about the whole thing not force people
to do it and every time i see one of
these stories where they lie and they
say things like the man grasped my hand
and said please
i just wish i took the vet i'm like that
didn't happen dude because there was one
woman who claimed it and then a bunch of
people called like they pulled up the
cdc data on the hospital and found out
she made it up oh my gosh yeah it's like
dude no no no one in these age groups
were in your hospital with kova this is
or how about the the ivermectin thing in
oklahoma when all these outlets fall for
it this is why there are skeptics
because the media lies over and over
again is the oklahoma ivermectin thing
where they said 70
of all the poison control calls were for
people that but then it turned out
percent seventy percent of the two
percent of the calls
so like one point six percent of the
calls that's a great story we have yet
to go on that on this show did you talk
about the on your no that's hilarious i
was gonna say another thing is like
imagine if covert was actually as bad as
they're saying it or pretending it is or
promoting no no no no no no we wouldn't
be having this conversation
if the government for the most part
stayed out of it i feel like and i i'm
just such a believer in the free markets
and the people and you know people
making the right decisions uh based on
the truth and based on the information i
feel like if there was an actual disease
killing let's say five to ten percent of
the people it touches i feel like we
would make personal
yes changes to our own life it would be
my life's goal to help people joey yeah
covey home that actually seems bad
people my age are dying i'm not gonna go
out listen listen
is exactly as bad as they say it is
covid is absolutely as bad as they've
been saying it is the problem is they're
cowards who want to live in bubble wrap
in a safe space instead of realizing
that freedom comes with risks so i'm the
kind of guy who's like hey we decided to
move out in the middle of nowhere
they're bears out here and uh
somebody recently was posting about how
like there were bears outside their
houses we get messages flagged in our
facebook group it's like guys guys
there's a bear everyone you know stay
inside wild cats and stuff
yeah welcome to mountains we choose to
live in these areas we have more freedom
and greater risk that's on us the
problem is when you get these people who
see something like covid and then say
shut her down everyone even you in the
middle of nowhere
you work from home vaccine mandate
another thing is like if i died from
covid tomorrow i don't want to be used
politicized as oh he was anti-vaccine or
whatever he should have he only would
have lived if he only took the vaccine
if i die from covert tomorrow the end of
the day that's my choice because i
didn't if i didn't take the vaccine and
i died from it or because i went out and
got myself sick
that's not me you do you got to be real
careful about dying from covet and dying
with code
because some people will die from like a
heart attack and they have covet and
then they get countered
one of the biggest spins that they did i
think it was in california when when it
first started it was like an 18 year old
17 year old kid uh died with covid but
apparently he was doing steroids and his
like heart exploded and they tested him
and he had covid and they ran the
headlines 17 year old high school
student
young healthy played football died with
from covet however they did this men
try to scare younger people at the time
they do it with you know when a baby
dies from coveted too they do all these
spins you read the article and you go
down to the bottom you're like okay so
that's the truth but they got the
headline out let's let's talk about
what's going on with the executive
branch because as much as i think
these like democrat voters who are just
let's just use a cliche sheeple
who are just bleating at the at the
calls of their grifter class and the
executive branch i think joe biden knows
exactly what he's doing i said earlier
that the the the the mandate the decree
over you know vaccine mandates is
intended just to cause chaos and so
dissent within the within the states and
break apart the bonds of this country
and i think i've got some more hard
evidence for that
from john bogage i'm sorry jacob bogage
he is a washington post reporter
covering the u.s postal service and he
says
news
white house official tells me usps
workers are not included in president
biden's vaccine requirement but we
strongly encourage them to comply with
these standards it's a massive chunk of
the federal workforce
644 000 and growing that's not required
to be vaccinated this is stunning one of
the things we've learned during the
pandemic is the postal service is a key
part of the national infrastructure and
homeland security we've seen what's
happened to the service when there have
been pandemic related staffing shortages
but usps workers are exempt to put in
context osha will find a business more
than fourteen thousand dollars for
testing violation but the us postal
service a goliath of a federal agency is
exempt he says quick you write up on the
usps exemption then he links to the
source do you know what this means that
means that biden knows that they would
refuse and have to fire a bunch of
postal services and we can't yep
that means when it comes to u.s federal
infrastructure they said
we can't have deal with staffing
shortages in the post office
exempt them but that means biden knows
this mandate will result in massive
resignations across the country
so it's not it's it's intentional
he knows what's going to happen from
this and he's shielding the federal
government from it the only thing i can
see is that they want people to quit
they want the labor shortages they want
the staffing they want the food
shortages they want the collapse of
business
they know it is happening they want
freedom-loving people to not be able to
properly contribute to the society
anymore they want to it's the it's it's
the great
they might be stupid and afraid it might
be it might be that it might not be
anything malicious they really think
they're helping is that possible no no
no no no no no no he thinks he's saving
people no this is the point
for for the white for biden to come out
and be like yeah he knows we are going
to exempt the post office
and they're they're concerned about
staffing shortages they know the mandate
will just result in people quitting
their jobs at a time when we have 10.9
million job openings a record number we
only filled 235 000 positions and it's
expected to get worse because the great
resignation is escalating then joe biden
does this
signaling he knows this will result in
mass resignations yo i hope you're ready
for the shortages google search closed
comma shortages and have fun scrolling
through the tens of thousands of news
stories every day for the months about
every business that's closed due to
labor and supply shortages and if you
quit your job over not getting the
vaccine i think in most places i don't
know how if it's a federal thing or a
state thing you don't even qualify for
any benefits or unemployment
they're not gonna let you what if you
get fired if you refuse to quit and then
they have to terminate you i don't know
but they're trying to because nowadays
like if there's so many job openings
there's so much benefits that you can do
where you can quit your job and and just
live off the government
until you find another job which there
are tons of jobs for you to find they
kind of want to make it harder for you
to do any of that they don't want you to
get any unemployment
i don't remember
the end of the federal benefits the
eviction moratorium is over and a lot of
conservatives have been like oh this is
good it means people go back to work and
i'm like no it doesn't
people are quitting their jobs right now
they caught the great resignation we
lost i think 11 million jobs over three
months from uh it was april may and june
11 million jobs we didn't add that many
we we we added
not like two point something million
so people it's it's they're quitting
their jobs they're resigning you can't
get unemployment when you do that i love
how under trump when the lockdowns were
starting to come out trump beat all the
job growth expectations all of it beat
all of it like by flying colors and as
soon as biden came in immediately under
shorting them by like large margins like
immediately there's a point where i say
it feels like it's on purpose yeah
because
this action they took with protecting
the post office shows they know they
know it's going to destroy the economy
the thing is i i keep coming to the
point it's like why would even like the
deep state or the people you know
whoever's pulling the strings behind
biden if they had america's best
interest in mind why would they be doing
all this and usually the the thought
process i always come to is it must be
china yeah i don't think it's america
it's because it's only it has china this
all has china's best interest in mind
china's got uh um
access to trillions of dollars worth of
resources from the taliban now in
afghanistan america's economy is going
down in my opinion i do believe
cryptocurrency is probably going to end
up hurting the us dollar and we're just
printing stuff all willy-nilly like
everything we're doing china is looking
at it's like okay great we're going to
take advantage over these next four
years maybe even eight years maybe 12
years this is through city's trap
are you familiar we talk about it a bit
let me hear it
so they say whenever a
rising economic power is about to
displace the dominant economic power
war breaks out
well what's been happening between the
u.s and china there's been saber
rattling but there's been cyber war
cyber war's been active that's like
fourth generation warfare now we're in
we're in full-scale propaganda you got
john cena issuing his mandarin apology
over accidentally what do you call
taiwan a country when it comes to john
cena in that specific situation part of
me doesn't really blame him
because
i feel like at the same time he was
probably also looking out for everybody
involved in those films that he's been
making i blame him 100 because that's
the thing is bro you got to take
responsibility you can't let people off
the hook for this stuff i know i i don't
i don't blame him but i'm just trying to
put myself in his point of view you make
multiple hundred million dollar movies
you're the star of multiple hundred
million dollar movies you probably got
over hundreds of thousands of jobs on
the line between the marketing
department distribution people in
production your fellow actors everything
people in the management it's like you
know it branches out by hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth hundreds of
thousands of jobs based around him as
being the centerpiece
star of all these movies and all these
movies are now specifically uh pretty
much tailored around getting the chinese
distribution so if he came out and if he
was like i'm not going to apologize to
china f china they would instantly cut
every single movie deal he had uh either
some of these movies probably would have
been hundreds of millions of dollars in
the toilet gone or they would spend tens
of millions of dollars to replace him
good
but then it hurts so what hundreds of
thousands of people who had nothing to
do with anything too bad the people in
the production the people in the union's
too bad just all he has to do is we
shouldn't be doing deals with we should
concentration camps that are going to
pull something like we shouldn't
say do you want the movie or not have it
or leave it
but that but people are greedy
and so it's like look the people who did
those jobs probably would just probably
be ensued for hundreds of millions of
dollars too so good take it i mean maybe
people should be should shouldn't be
such spineless whiny babies i i'd kind
of draw the line between
i guess stupidity and and morality it's
obviously from a morality point of view
he should stud his stood his ground
maybe many people would but i feel like
from the stupidity
point of view it's like all you got to
do is say sorry to china and everything
gets to go keep going as normal or you
don't say sorry now you're going to be
in the fight for your life you know what
joey you're like you're right it's just
15 days it's just a mask it's just a
vaccine it's just a booster it's just a
boost every five months it's just your
twice daily advisor pill it's just it's
just it's just no you put your foot down
and you say sorry china i'm apologizing
for not apologizing okay i'm saying
sorry i'm not going to apologize to you
i just think more for him specifically
if i was in his shoes i i think it's
just going to open up a whole can of
worms of [ __ ] that he's not to deal with
the rest of his life just for
two little words yep
so you want to bend the knee to the
chinese communist party or do you want
to stand up and live on your face i
don't think that hollywood should even
be bending the knee at all to china
which they are the entire chinese china
offered you 50 million dollars to drop
50 million
to start praising the ccp and saying
communism is good you do it i wouldn't
go out of my way to start praising them
like someone like i guess lebron is
doing for example like he's you know
he's purposely not standing for the flag
kneeling um i'm pretty sure he's came
out and said some positive stuff about
china well he was like oh we shouldn't
get involved know i mean john cena
to my knowledge at least he's not going
out of his way to praise china he said
one thing about taiwan and then just
backtracked it and just went back his
own path i don't see him as someone
that's going out there praising the ccp
every chance he gets he was like hey you
said this one thing we can't have that
we're gonna lose billions of dollars
hundreds of thousand dollars worth of
jobs we're gonna sue you for 100 million
dollars all this all that all we need to
do is just issue this mandarin apology
personally i would cut my losses i would
do it and live to fight another day who
knows maybe john cena will come out in
10 years imagine if every single person
said no china
that has to come down to then people
should stop going to the movies and tell
well that's the thing is that's why the
nba doesn't care about the american
audience anymore because they're just
going to get all their money from china
because people like john cena will get
on his knee and and beg xi jinping
there's always going to be people that
would do that
right they're bad people
see this this is what we're experiencing
right now you've got a lot of people in
the united states i said this the other
day some people got mad i'm not
referring to any of our audiences
cowards this isn't we are a nation of
cowards i am not saying every person in
this country is a coward i'm not saying
the history of this nation is built on
cowardice quite the opposite i'm saying
our current generation is the good times
making weak men
we have a disproportionate amount of
cowards who won't speak up for
themselves or their own families to save
their own lives at their workplace and
now where are we
you know
we'll see where things go after this
maybe this is the point where biden
crank the heat up on the boiling pot and
the frogs are going to jump out
but i tell you there's probably going to
be a lot of people who still won't say
anything we still won't protest and if
you think it's bad right now you're
going to lose your job because of this
overreach by biden this is one of the
most extreme bits of overreach you know
acts of overreach we've seen in a long
time
if you do not speak now
i don't know what you can expect to have
a year from now
you know you're like but i have kids
yeah well i hope you're you like that's
what a lot of cops
teach your kid mandarin already you know
what i mean just start teaching them
mandarin while you're at it that's what
you're gonna i'm not even kidding yeah
no if you refuse to speak up and defend
your rights and stand up for your nation
and the constitution
my advice to you is to get you know um
rosetta stone mandarin right now that
means 100 seriously have your kids learn
learn it anyway i think mandarin's great
if we could communicate with the chinese
man that's that's the step we need well
there's a global peace they're going to
need it when china is the dominant
economic power putting pressure on the
u.s and straining us for resources
forcing us to adopt their cultural norms
right
we're we're going downhill from here i'm
just thinking about unity because you
were saying like i don't think
unification is necessarily the way and
i'm thinking like just bland unification
isn't like hitler unified germany he was
all about you we must unify the
fatherland
killing people so unity for the sake of
unity is not a net positive always what
what are we unifying behind the
fetiverse a decentralized crypto backed
economy
a new political system where we can
remove the representatives and have
direct representation i could see
unifying behind a system
but like the constitution american
original constitution the unified behind
that it wasn't unifying behind george
washington and his ideas was unifying
behind a document you know you know why
the constitution's amazing it's the
amendment process the problem is the
country has become so divided we can we
can't amend it i mean like i mean we've
had amendments in the past few decades
but at this point we are really close to
a convention of states which would be
fantastic we need i think only a couple
more states to be republican the problem
is i don't think the republicans are
going to do anything but that's we could
do that a
convention of states is probably the
direction we should go with the internet
the ability to get 100 million people on
with their eyes on one thing at a time
yeah i mean
most of these republicans are all just
paid off by the same people the
democrats are paying off and i feel like
for instance china has a population on
their side just an immense large
population and that's going to be one of
their biggest you know
leg ups against america and i feel like
that is one of the reasons why
the democrats are just letting people
from the southern border just flood into
this country
just to increase our population hand
them all money create more consumers
hey everyone coming in oh we can give
you ten thousand dollars a month go buy
an iphone i'll go use amazon here go get
it house it's like it's slate everything
look when you've got
half the country cheering for the end of
the american government i'm like you'd
think people in the american government
would be like i have a problem with this
the issue is they're not
destroying it they're subverting it to
use the infrastructure of the government
to implement things they want
so joe biden bypasses the two other
branches of government and one of the
most brazen acts of executive authority
we've ever seen i'll be fi you know i'll
be honest obama straight up killed
people american citizens without charge
of trial bush created that stupid
patriot act that's bush bush signed the
president presidential directive 51
giving the president the ability to
overthrow the us government creating a
new constitutional government with a
with a continuity coordinator a
centralized that it creates one unified
branch in control of the other branches
and the only requirements are that there
be severe loss of life somewhere in the
world
so it's not been tested in the courts
supreme court would say screw if you
can't do this but it'll be interesting
to see now that joe biden has completely
undermined the supreme court and the
legislative branch if he does say due to
the widespread death of the pandemic and
the refusal of people to get vaccinated
i hereby invoke national security
presidential directive 51 there may have
been an update to it like a newer
version
where he says we will create a new
enduring constitutional government with
a new continuity coordinator we're in
charge and that will it will only be
until 18 months from now and then it
will go back to normal that's what they
always say you know that's okay
and then there will be
peace
come on man and then you'll have you
know uh flagler drop down
you'll have marjorie taylor green and
lauren
yeah high-fiving no they'll be standing
in in in the senate you know in the in
the in the congressional building and
then lauren boba will say so this is how
liberty dies to thunderous applause
he wasn't joking tim wasn't i thought
jim was joking he wasn't jealous
what do you mean what were you saying i
was joking
it's a star wars reference
but it's like kind of true
dude i know we're on the verge i mean
bush put us on the verge of a
totalitarian dictatorship with these
things that he signed the patriot act
50 directly
it's not
it's been since uh who who is that
crackpot loser woodrow wilson woodrow
was that who it was yeah yeah was he was
he the federal reserve guy yeah he was
bad news we call him the most fascist
worst president that guy was a jagmeet
awful like what's our way out of this
now
we're gonna have a crypto
crypt that's a big part of it you know i
made a whole podcast episode talking
about how i believe crypto could be
used to lead us into a freer nation i
think it's gonna take a generation for
that to happen because the younger
generation like us we understand what we
get it's not about bitcoin not about
ethereum it's about the technology of
being decentralized kind of off the
federal grid and i believe the free
market will have a lot of solutions to
our current system and the reason why
you're in your in the system now you got
to build credit you know you got to have
enough payments to get a loan to buy a
house and you're all part of the
centralized grid and i feel like in the
future maybe 5 10 years from now the
decentralized
system will be able to replace a lot of
that credit and loan structure
i hear you but like i mean part of you
has to admit how cool would it be if
like biden showed up for a presidential
address in like a black robe with his
hood over his face and he's like the
attempt
the republicans will be hunted down just
kidding if he did that i would have some
just kidding
no i mean like if he seriously was like
the united states will be reformed into
the first
planetary empire galactic empire well
we're not galactic yeah i would be like
i really hate this but oh it's so cool
to see yeah finally
oh and everyone cheers we're pretty
close to that i was thinking about the
uh the idiosyncrasies of crypto and
smart contracts and things that could
like the complexities of what we could
build so like you'd be in like north
korea or not north korea but wherever
you're you're in some other country i
send you some crypto which triggers a
smart contract that tells tim's
crypto to move to another account that
then tells the lights to turn on in a
city so like you can have these complex
chains of events that all occur just
from moving one token that all happens
automatically and a lot of people who
are anti-crypto right now um they're
like oh bitcoin it's being controlled by
the elites and i think to a certain
extent a lot of these big
cryptocurrencies are probably being
controlled by like elon musk can make a
couple tweets and make it pump 50 or
dump 50 percent which i think elon musk
is probably one of the biggest frauds of
our entire generation right now um
yeah you stop doing that you've got to
look at some of his projects like he's
elon musk's entire business model is
based off of getting gullible democrats
that want to believe in the future and
they just spend all the all your tech
tax dollars i mean what do you mean
spacex is particularly successful i mean
tesla's not i've been watching a lot of
stuff online like breaking down like his
hyperloop stuff well he's been through
so many things and it's kind of like he
went to a future of tomorrow conference
and just like picked up a bunch of ideas
and they would break down the ideas even
his semi truck i don't want to get too
much into the weeds with this stuff but
when you break down the economic
viability of a lot of his projects
doesn't exist
it doesn't it's it's cheaper to use just
railroad well tesla for instance was uh
uh
it's effectively subsidized because of
the the tax credit you got it made it
made it profitable but now that that's
real that that's gone i guess it's not
gonna make sense to make the cars
anymore
so you know i guess better batteries and
i was watching like uh i think a
california representative went to his
like hyperloop thing and i guess they
were putting a bunch of money into it
even that like underground vegas
railroad that not railroad yeah that's
underground tunnel yeah it was supposed
to go 200 miles an hour it's like 30
miles an hour and it's just like a tesla
car at a time it's like a complete flop
but they're getting all the money from
the government a bunch of gullible
democrats that believe in clean energy
the clean world the future and they're
just throwing money at him starlink is
one of the most important infrastructure
projects
of our generation apparently that's
another bust of his oh why it's on it's
working
i don't know i watched i didn't get too
much into louise about the starlink but
i was i was watching something i got to
look more i don't even want to talk
about it if we can get high-speed
low-latency internet everywhere in the
country
i can set up shop in
in central west virginia start hiring
locals in west virginia bring back jobs
to these areas
i mean that would be tremendous for
small town rural you know middle america
these people get their jobs back they'd
have they'd have purpose their families
would start improving it would start
revitalizing a lot of this country when
we we recently drove into central west
virginia you see the sad state of a lot
of people's lives in these places where
their jobs are leaving some places in
west virginia doing really really well
actually they're bringing in more
industry power plants and things like
that but a lot of these there are a lot
of towns that used to be like railway
towns and the railway stops going there
or coal mines dry up and now all of a
sudden you've got a generation of you
know families uh multiple generations
and there's nothing left for them so
this the towns start collapsing people
flood the cities desperate for work the
cities are crooked and corrupt we get
starlink up and running you're going to
see all of these areas light back up and
it's going to it's going to help put an
end to the opioid epidemic giving people
purpose
and then giving them jobs and bringing
all these different
i guess there's so many different jobs
based on technology you can be doing
remotely you could have people working
in just like central pa
central west virginia and wyoming
montana
all of a sudden nebraska these small
towns that are falling apart come right
back to life
saves the saves a lot of people yeah
that's big that's why i'm rooting for
starlink man i'm like get it done right
now i think they've got i don't know how
many satellites they have active but i
know their new york satellite is active
their array in new york which means if
you are in the new york area you're
probably getting your starlink activated
right now it's like 100 megabits up and
down
bro if we had starlink we could do this
show anywhere we could we could
theoretically you're not supposed to we
put on rv and you get a 500 mile range
right now the satellites are cell locked
which means if you have a new york
satellite it only works in the new york
region so it's like a 500 mile radius
this says there's 1600 of them up right
now yeah but they're not they're not
there's a guy you've got to watch on
youtube there's a guy you got to watch
on youtube i don't remember if you i
don't know if he made a starling video
on it or not his name's thunderfoot oh i
know that guy yeah he makes a lot of
videos breaking down a lot of elon
musk's projects and because i was
i was never an elon musk fan because i i
always knew the history of tesla and i
guess
his business history elon musk and how
he kind of rewrote his entire history to
make himself look a lot better than he
really is
um and you always knew about that so i
never liked elon musk until he started
tweeting out like against gavin newsom
and pro-freedom i was like okay maybe
i'll like this guy he was all about
kryptos the future's like maybe i like
him until he started manipulating crypto
prices and he completely posting about
falsehoods about bitcoin's like
efficiency when it comes to you know uh
emissions and stuff and just it was all
like false i was like wait okay this guy
actually might be just full of [ __ ] he
might be completely controlled by people
um and then i started going down the
rabbit hole i was like oh let me see
more [ __ ] that he promotes um check
out double check thunderfoot stuff
because he debunked a piece of
technology i was working on and then it
got rebunked like they found out his
deep blood wasn't he got re-bumped yeah
water condenses the air goes down
underground turns cranks and then comes
back up and out and condenses water he's
like there's not it's not cold enough or
it's not hot enough underground so yeah
no i'm sure that's why you should be
wrong about something yeah watch out i
don't know too much i also like his
tunnel uh elon's tunnel his boring
company because i think once we go to
mars we're all gonna be living
underground
personally it might be a few hundred
years from now yeah yeah like we're
subsidizing technology that's like 80
years ahead of its time yeah is that
that might happen we're gonna live
i don't think so me and you may not
there's no magnetosphere not yet
how are we going to make a magnet we're
going to ignite are we going to send
aaron eckhart down to the center of mars
to drop a bunch of nukes and ignite
rotation
in the core
i don't even think there is we need to
start rotation in the core is there a
core i would imagine yeah this might be
a couple thousand years away if we live
if we survived that long you guys ever
see that movie the core yeah pretty sure
aaron had eckhart that was in it
they go down yeah what a silly movie
right one of those like stupid doomsday
movies
yeah there's like a whole bunch of those
dooms and now we got the pandemic i talk
about life art imitating life like
people it's like they wanted this this
disaster you know we've had these stupid
zombie movies and like the end of days
as movies and all this like what a
disappointing disaster the disaster
isn't the actual disaster itself it's
the reaction to the disaster what is the
real disaster what if we use an ai
to create
tv shows
algorithmically procedurally generated
entertainment so instead of having that
for the news
well yeah they have robots that write
articles it's really funny there was one
article about me that said timothy poole
was raised by his mother his father
daniel poole and his mother timothy
daniel poole what and then i was like
the robots bless their hearts they're
trying my mom's name is not timothy
daniel four might could you imagine that
like your dad's name isn't
that's picky
imagine imagine your mom and dad all
have like
a
just
meeting a woman with a man's name and
having daniel as their middle name and
being like wow this is amazing but
anyway yeah they're trying about that
but imagine this imagine instead of
creating hiring actors and all that
stuff we just create
simulated universes
where
you know simulate simulated people live
their lives
and then you create an interesting
storyline you kick it off and then let
the ai play it out and people turn it on
and watch you already have uh digital
influencers no no what i'm saying is
no i mean
an entire entire planet of people where
you actually can end up getting an
unlimited stream
of the movie what new guy free guy free
guy yeah that's a video game i'm saying
imagine if we procedurally generated a
planet with people with countries and we
just watched the interactions for our
own entertainment and what if that's the
world we're living in now
yeah that's us yeah so it's like all
this crazy stuff that's happening is
like
the the simulation they say why are we
being maybe just people who are like
interested in watching all this [ __ ]
well it's entertainment it's like man i
love watching that that that show they
made they're real housewives
procedurally generated
american idol procedurally we got to
hire anybody just the computer just did
it and we watched it what if on the
trees planted us you know how we move
really
we move so fast relative to the trees so
from trees perspective we're zipping
around like lightning around it super
fast what if 100 million years ago it
planted humans and then it's white it's
watched us grow this whole time
destroyed but to a tree like
9 000 years is like a day so they get to
watch us evolve over time and they get
to watch us chop them down
that wasn't part of the plan
when tree beard saw what saruman had
done he wasn't too happy about it so
yeah yeah we've given him there's
nothing there there is no word in what
is it
or common did you see the movie uh or
free guy at all
yeah i thought it was good yeah because
they they did explore a lot of what you
were just saying well but the idea for
yeah right so his ai is he got
consciousness and then at the end
they're you know their utopia was oh
it's just a no one there's people here
they get the watch right right okay yeah
you're saying yeah yeah yeah so that
well spoiled you spoiled the movie i
guess i'm still going to watch it right
now incredible yeah
it's pretty good
but it's it's you know maybe that's the
simulation we're in i mean like when you
see how
luke's got this shirt lukakowski where
it's like 1984 brave new world and what
was the other dystopia youtube oh just
you know it's three dystopian novels
i don't i don't know
fahrenheit maybe it's and it's like
they're all together and says you are
here yeah and i'm like you got to put v
for vendetta in there because before
vendetta is the one where a virus got
released and killed a bunch of kids and
the government then locked everybody
down and issued yeah is that a book did
they write a book viva vendetta was a
graphic novel
but it was um
the movie is different i think the
graphic novel was like a series it's
very different because um
i love how people adopted the guy fox
mask when guy fox was like a theater a
theater
uh what's the word
theocratic fascist is that one thing
enough oh he was yeah he wanted to blow
up parliament to instill a christian
theocracy and okay that's incredible yes
all my i don't know that's not a good
guy you know well what we're talking
about i guess some of the theories of uh
existence i i've been thinking about
this one lately i wanna know what you
think and it's probably already a theory
and i feel like
what if
because everything i feel like we're
experiencing we're experiencing memories
like right now it's already the past it
already happened yeah like we're already
and we all know time is relative
so what if the big bang or everything
what if it all just happened instantly
time wise
and they're just over in a blink of one
cajillionth of a second and we're just
living memories it's all it's it's all
relative right so like
you know it's all happened but we're
just in the memory you ever use like
universe simulator whatever it's called
i've seen you you just speed up time and
watch years passing like an eye and it's
like it's like you're saying about trees
watching us zap around
time's relative man um i was reading
about there's like these tiny flies
they're so small that they don't fly
they swim
wow because it's a fluid of air yes
because they're actually like gripping
the molecules and pushing them as if
they're swimming and not flying it's
crazy we might be able to do that one
day and another thing that's crazy is
like
on on our fingertip it's like
pretty much like an entire universe of
organisms living on our fingertips like
size is relative time is relative
another thing is math math is like
literally it's crazy how that's like the
key to like everything and well let's
just say we're mapping we're mapping the
source code of the universe but another
thing is that
that gets me thinking is
there's an infinite number of numbers
from zero to one
right
it's like if you break that down on like
time in seconds
it's like there's an infinite amount of
points of a second within now just watch
uh just watch ant-man and the wasp man
the quantum yeah
but in physics there's a thing called
the casmir effect where when two numbers
get close enough together they basically
fuse the two pieces of matter when they
get close enough together they suck they
get sticky and no one really knows
exactly why you know outer space metal
does it in a vacuum you can take pieces
of metal and just yeah it seems like it
gets so close that it pushes
the matter out of the way between it and
then it creates a vacuum and then it
sucks itself together it's it's the
oxidized layer that prevents metals from
bonding
so i wonder if numbers theoretically
they don't theoretically numbers will
always get half as close half as close
half as close but in physics there's the
cashmere effect another crazy thing is i
guess the 80 20 rule
i think it's i forgot there's an actual
name for it if you want to google it
real quick it's like a phenomenon that
happens in pretty much almost everything
there's exceptions to the rule but it's
like uh um 80 of your businesses from 20
of your customers that holds throughout
with like
i was like 80
of all the words ever said and typed is
like actually 20
of the actual
vocabulary and like that kind of 80 20
rule and the way it like progressively
decreases from like the number one most
used this to the second to the third is
like always follows the same trend lines
in the same path like throughout almost
everything we gotta go to super chats
if you haven't already my friends smash
the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com because
we're gonna have a members only segment
coming up usually goes up around 11 or
so p.m you'll you'll not want to miss
that
and uh being a member means you're
supporting our work
as things get crazier and crazier we're
definitely gonna need that support but
let's uh let's see what y'all got to say
all right let's see
all right
pedro enrique says time to be optimistic
u.s isn't doomed by thucydides trap
cn bubbles slowly bursting as its
biggest real estate company china
evergrand shows to be 19 times debt to
earnings u.s is bleeding but china's
falling
wow that's what peter was saying last
night
patrick conover says biden said he's
going to use his presidential power to
remove governors who oppose him the
authoritarianism is growing right before
our eyes well he said get them out of
the way
biden purging
yeah uh will
will hallman says biden purging anyone
who doesn't lick the boot
camp
yep michael fernando says peak clown
world is upon us that corpse in the
white house has lost his damn mind and
gone full tyrant we will not comply
and then he says 1776 will come again aj
a great podcast tim cass crew and then
he shouts out stick sticks hacks and
hammer we'd love to have sticks on the
show you gotta get a sound bite of uh
alex jones what does he say 1776. well
commence again he's like yelling it was
he on it i thought that was a big
mistake i think it was on
right that's always been the problem
i've had with alex jones going back to
all of this stuff is that he always
whenever he gets on tv he just says he's
nuts you know charles manson too he did
uh some video or news thing where they
took a picture of him and he did a crazy
face and that picture got propagated
forever you got to be careful when
you're in the public eye of making a
fool of yourself on purpose because that
will track you forever so don't do it i
can destroy you like that guy that one
election goes yeah
yeah that like kind of like destroyed
them
i don't remember i don't remember i
remember being you know who was that who
was that yeah yeah i don't remember that
guy oh nobody remembers them
hillary clinton's vp pick in 2008 or
something wasn't it i don't i just
remember being young and watching the
trend like i used to watch comedy
central like the late night howard dean
dean
i think he was working with it i can't
believe that one you know was it yeehaw
or something yeah
we should pull it up and play it yeah
we gotta read super chat another day
martin edgar says if you look at the
executive order legislators and their
staff are exempt from the vaccine
mandate
interesting
alan scharrer says it's never a good
idea to quote terrible star wars but in
this case it's the best quote i can
think of and this is how the republic
ends to applause didn't you say liberty
dies and this is sound thunder is the
thunder's applause someone look up the
quote i look it up well the the new star
wars movies made the the prequels good
yeah yep
i enjoy the prequels now yes why
it's it's more fun now watching it i
guess uh because it's corny you kind of
know it's a little bit corny and if you
like star wars you're like kind of like
into the lore of it and just watching it
all happen and the new ones that kind of
just destroy it all what's your favorite
force power
ah
i don't know when i was a kid i always
wanted to move things oh like whatever
that is like you know force push or
force pull yeah just what about you
um probably the ability to influence the
midi-chlorians to preserve life itself
well that's powerful you must have
mastered both the light and the dark
well tr if you would like if you truly
want to understand the nature of the
force you can't be scared of it like the
jedi are speak the truth that's right
we're just referencing star wars too
much
tyler b says you think the trucker
shortage is bad now wait until ninety
percent of them park until this vaccine
or deal is over this country will come
to a screeching halt in days truckers
have no respect for biden i'll tell you
this and ultimatum won't go as they plan
and maybe that's the point
maybe we need that maybe it's a great
reset oh you know one problem with that
is it'll it'll come to a halt in a day
but we won't see the effects until the
back of the truck the momentum is
carried past where it stopped so could
take a couple months take a while be
careful
it's like when there's like a snake in
the road on the highway
everyone just stops and like the snake
gets bigger and bigger until it starts
to pick back up again yeah okay xblcorn
says you are mistaken about the banking
rules coming they want to track every
transaction and every account that has
at least six hundred dollars in it it is
not for transactions over six hundred
dollars i did not hear that that is the
first i've heard that i feel like you
could google search this it's uh i think
it's icba.org
and google search that then google
search consumer
um announcement or something like that
it should pop right up because so many
people have been searching for it google
autofills it did you find it oh i got
the independent community banking
thing consume if you google it it should
autofill the url you need
i-c-i-c-b-a-dot or i don't use google i
use duckduckgo
all right let's see
adam austin says i'm an electrical
contractor in columbus we are down to
eight employees two thousand dollar
sign-on bonus can't hire anyone we are
scheduling estimates two weeks out wow
if this persists
at what point does
the average person at their job just go
why am i even here i'm gonna leave
i i can't remember any store that i've
been to recently that doesn't have a
help wanted something outside of it it's
like every single one everyone yeah
a raw says hey tim long time viewer and
i work for a company that supplies parts
for the military and this decree would
affect me and i will stand on my
principles and i will not comply
good for you good sir
america 76 says this has everything to
do with rushing the destruction of the
republican free market choice in
capitalism it is absolutely zero to do
with any virus all of this has been
intentional from the jump
yeah
the great resignation the great reset
the the post office exemption
they know it's coming if people really
still can't see that they're just
exploiting this tragedy just for more
power i mean
it's it's crazy there i've been seeing a
lot of people wake up especially on tick
tock recently than making videos i made
a huge mistake voting for biden i feel
like that's like the number one thing
i've seen you never really see people
saying i made a mistake voting for trump
people if anything they're realizing oh
wow things weren't actually that bad
under trump he was just orange man bad
now there's actual bad things whereas
like on the trump the biggest issues
were net neutrality and and and uh trans
bathroom issues mean tweets and mean
tweets i can confirm that guys super
chat yeah the biden administration this
is from icpa.org the body administration
is proposing required financial
institutions report the irs all
transactions of all business and
personal accounts worth more than six
hundred dollars whoa
that's a lot of reporting wow
well well there you go tax season will
be cray cray and maybe that's to get to
the next step where they do these
vaccine mandates and how do they enforce
them the irs
the irs is going to say do you have the
records of your employees that have
tested negative we want them
and then when you're like no they're
going to be like okay it's 14 000 per
violation that means every week
if someone's not vaccinating they got to
get a test
every week if they don't have it or you
don't check 14 000 for each one
for each violation oh my god yeah and
they got it they got to get tested every
week that's why it's important to get
off the grid
off the system
be self-sufficient get away from cities
yeah ian made pawpaw bread earlier oh
it was good it was really good i lined
the pan with coconut oil because i
didn't want to use that spray-on pan
and uh man the the those uh the skin is
is toasty you guys should start like a
survival uh self-dependency we're not
survival we have chickens so it'll be
good seeing you guys as progression i
guess your vlog probably shows that yeah
yeah definitely it shows um our farm is
now defunct we harvested all the crops
and with a sword a lot of them well the
sunflowers i never cared for to begin
with i'm like what i don't want did you
see tim slicing through them with the
sandwiches
the chickens are eating the sunflower
seeds they love them i don't care for
them but the pumpkins were amazing and
we got pumpkin seeds amazing the
tomatoes amazing zucchini cucumbers
carrots basil jalapenos do you think the
government will ever start coming in and
taxing you on the stuff you grew
yourself not until you give it to
somebody yeah is going on but uh so one
of our so our chickens are now like um
have teamed up to have babies
so they all brewed there's like there's
three chickens that brooding is when
they're like sitting on the eggs and i
came out one day and i noticed that one
of the chickens was not with the group
and i was like oh it happened so i went
to look for and sure enough she's
sitting on all the eggs
but it's not just her eggs it's all they
all lay the eggs in the same spot even
though there's a bunch of different
spots later i come out and i see that
chicken katarina out doing her thing and
i'm like oh i guess she's not brooding
she's you know she's out just milling
about so i went in and i noticed that
vanessa was missing she was on the edge
taking turns then dorothy was on the
eggs and so these three chickens are
rotating shifts i love it sitting on the
ass normal how they operate like i guess
it actually is
yeah that chickens like to lay eggs in
the same place as other chickens because
they could they could lay eggs wherever
they want but they've decided all to lay
in this one spot
and they're taking turns when one
chicken gets up to go eat the other one
goes in and sits on the eggs that's so
cute it's gonna be interesting when
there's like 14 babies so we have we
have five black star chicken babies
these are a special breed where you mix
a rhode island red with a barred
plymouth rock and then we have three
baby uh three babies two of them
are leghorn
rhode island red mixes and one is an
easter egg and a rhode island red mix
because we have rhode island red rooster
and they're they're um two of i think
two of them are cockerels they're
they're gonna be roosters and one of
them is a pulit are they kind of like
organic chickens or they get filled with
like uh what do you mean organic we we
birthed them here they were we incubated
the eggs and they like uh like heavily
modified no no just regular chickens
yeah yeah like i know the modified ones
i think they start growing so big like
they break their legs right they break
their but it's really sad and they just
sit there laying eggs on they're just
like
that's not right yup it's
crazy they're bred to just self-destruct
themselves those gag orders are crazy
where you can't like record in those
those
factory farms that's so sick i think it
was like nathan for you i think it was
him
i forgot who it was someone did like a
whole loophole to put every single label
on on uh on his chicken like you know
chicken cutlets he made his own farm and
like you know what was uh
to get them classified as free range no
it was a movie the guy i think it was
the guy who did uh super size me i think
he did another movie and uh you know he
just put like a little opening for like
one square foot well they're free range
chickens they don't go outside and he
just did all the loopholes to put
everything on his label easily done
let's read some more cameron malouf says
truck drivers have a cdl which is
federally regulated i wonder how long it
will take before you have to get a
vaccine in order to renew your medical
card for your cdl could get bad more
shortages i think truckers would just be
like nah we out yeah oh yeah bye-bye
putin said no no mandates
just straight up get it out of the way
early we're not going to do that messiah
miguel says hey tim did you guys know
that california passed a per mile car
tax i am living in ground zero for the
new regime also i'm constantly getting
double charge for the membership on the
website ooh that's not good uh you can
always email members timcast.com that is
it's it's on the website that's where we
take care of all the stuff and um
we'll get it sorted we'll try and figure
it out but i i will say
uh send an email and we'll get more
specific i don't want to give anyone any
details or anything about people's
private stuff
what's this one mile per taxing per mile
yeah at the end of the year you got to
take your odometer and then submit it
your taxes and they tax you based on how
much you drove if you live in california
move to a swing state
don't move to texas don't move to
florida move to a swing state like
nevada if you want to move hit me up dm
me i got a realtor for you
but
we it's important i believe for us to
move republicans to move to swing states
because
15 000 more votes in nevada flips it
okay secure the elections 15 15 000.
that's nothing california you need
millions to flip it don't even waste
your time same thing with new york don't
even waste your time go somewhere with a
few thousand people can turn it red
by vox says or by evox says glad to see
your business is doing well tim elad was
a great pickup i think he's highly
underrated and hopefully your
partnership will generate good
visibility
keep it the great work guys that's right
elad is doing on the ground reporting at
a bunch of different protests and public
events
um i think so far mostly new york city
but he had you know he asks great
questions and he went to one where it
was uh union workers protesting the
mandates and this was a couple weeks ago
and they were like f trump f biden we
don't care we ain't doing it and then
it's it's good to see when you have
people on the ground reporting it's
fantastic
all right
karasu matcha says hey tim trucker here
it won't take much for us to go on
strike we already hate going into these
cities and that was before the riots
during and after we are playing hot
potato over whose turn to tack a load
into them
well there you go not surprising how
long before we start seeing trucks get
raided in the highway like it's going on
in south africa i think that happens
yeah yep it's gonna happen
notoriously wise says tim you're wrong
about segregation the train companies
were lobbying to desegregate why pay
fuel for two fifty percent empty
segregated cars the market tried to end
it stopped by the individual state
legislators and their guns oh
interesting didn't know that
that's interesting
makes sense
alex aiello says tim just want to say as
an accountant what did we do to be your
example i have been feeling oddly
attacked as of late keep up the good
work oh when i said like you're an
accountant and then like your job
mandates vaccines or something um i
don't know it seems like uh a good like
when you think of someone working in an
office somewhere in a city you know you
know accountant mm-hmm yeah i guess i
don't know just the go-to job sits at a
desk yeah that should that's a
compliment yeah it's like it's like the
job you know that's what i think of you
said it at a desk too
that's true that's right start seeing
podcasters there you go ethan davis says
v for vendetta every anyone i certainly
think
yeah i haven't seen it in 20 years but
it was great
uh malia cortez says love what tim said
in one of his earlier segments we're in
one of those stupid movies here's a
movie example biden just ordered 66 to
us i stole that quote
yep
yep we're we got a little bit in 1984
government overreach spying we got a
little bit of brave new world your video
games and your social media to stimulate
we got a little bit of fahrenheit 451
people overly offended wanting to burn
books and shut down information and we
get your v for vendetta pandemic
resulting in government authoritarianism
hey it's all there right for us to to
soak up how about that all these uh
all these uh these stories from the past
there's these kind of warnings
like beef and that vendetta and what he
just said it's like it's all just coming
true now like every single one of these
mornings like you're gonna wake up yet
people like every single piece of media
alexandra battic says tim i just watched
atlas shrugged it needs to be remade for
a modern audience i have theater and
directing experience shall we start pool
studios i do not think we could afford
to make an atlas shrugged movie
there is like a three-part movie where
it's like each part has different actors
or whatever
interesting good story
i definitely think it's really preachy
it's just like huh yeah libertarians
magnificent devil says we do not have a
free market today government regulations
allow big corporations to gatekeep the
most powerful and influential industries
making the barrier to entry
insurmountable for most agreed but that
is a free market by definition
no it isn't free market doesn't mean
anyone can do anything there's all sorts
of regulations they're giving these
trillion dollar companies in california
extra perks over small business they
want to keep them there them from
leaving to go to texas the only reason
why they have the largest economy
they want to keep that title i should
clarify for sure i was i was being
tongue-in-cheek um it's it's not
uh
it's not a real free market even though
they call it a free market it's
completely guarded by the government
that's setting up regulations and
pipelines we've got to strive towards a
freer market like a real free market
could be dangerous because you get
corporate monopoly so you need to always
have a sidearm to be able to break it
down i feel like for the most part i
think the will of the people especially
now in this communication age i feel
like
it's more
more likely for solutions maybe it's not
perfect i don't know but to emerge
within the system yeah i think you're
right
tim rose says got covered in january of
this year donated my platelets and
plasma to help before the vaccine came
out why is natural immunity getting
short under the stick love your show by
the way
why is monoclonal antibodies being
ignored
is it it's expensive i guess yeah two
grand is it i think you mentioned that i
might have i thought that you were the
one that said that but isn't this like
this has got to be
like saving lives
stuff yeah monoclonal antibodies
so for somebody who's like get sick get
sick and go to the hospitals i mean we
don't just let them die i just can't
take the blinders it's like everyone
straight ahead get the vaccine straight
ahead everyone and it's like dude
there's these other pieces of info look
around let's let's look at this they're
like no no no keep going forward like
what's the
that's the east verboten reminds me of
that music video um
in a pink floyd music video where
they're all just marching off into the
grinder
oh god all right prc says we truckers
need to unite the vaccinated and
unvaccinated don't take runs into states
and businesses who mandate vaccines and
passports nothing happens until
something moves vaccines are good but
mandates are evil i completely agree
with that
the issue is
government shouldn't be dealing with
your medical stuff i just shouldn't be
unless it's a unless it's that's the
thing unless it's a real
health threat no no i don't know i mean
at some point if that's the whole
purpose is you've got to protect the
herd
i disagree i think
i don't think the government should be
getting involved regardless ever though
i mean because the thing is if there was
a virus that was killing as many people
as you know would be declared you know
like something like the black plague and
maybe that's a little bit too extreme
well like was it was smallpox was like
what 20 or something yeah it was massive
people are dying from things they'll
take it upon them risk to reward on
vaccine if i get sick and i have a 20
chance of dying maybe i'll i'll probably
take the vaccine i think at that point
i'll take my chances because ian we're
in a pandemic well people they call it a
pandemic yeah it is abandoned it is
technically by definition yeah by by
literal definition global epidemic and
by the millions of people around the
world who have died and the 650 000 in
the united states it's a pandemic does
it warrant the extreme degree at which
they're going in my opinion
no like mandates and all this stuff it's
like yo i get it it's bad novel virus
mutations all that stuff scary not good
it's not airborne ebola
so the issue is people need to be able
to assess the risks themselves there can
be things like this like
you know if you're don't don't cough on
people there can be like like the social
distancing makes sense it was like hey
stand six feet apart right you know i
actually think wearing a mask even when
it comes to private businesses
it comes to schools and kids it starts
getting murky
you know but
when people are sick they wear a mask
when people
those are things where i'm like okay
maybe we do some restrictions we protect
the vulnerable we get back to work you
know instead they've been like iron fist
shut it down i never i never wore a mask
people into nursing homes for the first
40 years of my life i never wore a mask
for illness and i never it was never a
problem no one was never part they were
like look at those people in japan
wearing masks how weird yeah and people
should have you think if they're so they
get so dirty so quick you gotta wash
them like daily get new ones
there's a lot of people i see in the
super chat we're like they're saying
basically because of this i will never
get
vaccinated i'm like that's the problem
i'm gonna fix listen
can you hear this because i hear this
every day i'm gonna fix this i promise
it's the joint on this this microphone
why is it making that noise we sprayed
it down
yeah i gotta take it apart and get in
there some yeah
all right let's see
aaron tabor says tim you've mentioned
dehumanization before i've seen people
on twitter regularly referring to
republicans and unvaxed people as plague
rats yes
frequently um and that's part of these
steps towards genocide no don't refer to
them as vermin don't do it you're
calling people animals and maggots don't
do this
it's not funny that was a keith
olbermann thing why won't you just
do what the state tells you because
we're america yeah this is america i
thought it was america
i remember when keith olbermann canceled
his show we did it it's it's imminent
trump's going to be removed from office
no
just nothing none of that ever happened
that dude's nuts guys crazy you know who
you know that's just howard stern what a
loser he's starting to whoa
is a loser i was trending on twitter
because i called howard a loser true
though i was such a fan of howard stern
when i first watched his movie
i was like
yeah i was like oh wow this is cool he's
like going against the system whatever
he's a thing and then he just became
this corporate chill was never against
the system
george carlin challenged the system got
arrested for saying naughty words did
stand-up bits where he basically told
the the modern sensibilities to screw
off he screams racial slurs and as a
part of his joke
and he was anti-establishment howard
stern was just riding the wave yeah he's
like oh people like this stuff yo they
put him on tv they put him on the radio
they gave him the ability to do this he
was not anti-establishment he was the
establishment it was just that boomers
liked edgy humor gen xers came up saying
okay we can do edgy humor too boomers
are retiring and gen xers are feckless
for the most part so they're just like
what should we do oh the millennials are
yelling in my ears there's another rage
against the machine situation yep right
right right behind the machine granted
uh howard stern is a boomer so he's the
definition of okay boomer when he's like
f their freedom i want the freedom to
live oh well i def your freedom i want
the freedom to live yeah like why do you
get to say who gets freedom sorry you
know this guy is like
talk about somebody who built a career
on being you know a jag off and just
being offensive and it's like the trope
i don't know if he actually did this but
the joke was that you know firing hot
dogs at women bikinis and stuff like
that just this sheer absurdity of his
show and the middle juice and then there
was michael mouse tweeted that one of
his guys his wife one of the people who
worked for him his wife was dealing with
cancer and howard stern just like made
fun of him for being sad and then when
he launched a gofundme to help save his
wife howard stern just didn't contribute
at all even though he's worth like half
a half a billion dollars
yo these are not good people they are
bad people they don't give they don't
support they don't help people out yo i
donate to save people's pets all the
time heck yeah i've done it a lot
actually
probably too much
because you're writing that off on
i think you can do it charitable giving
i will make you
ran roy says alex jones will run in 2024
and we will make the frog straight again
yes i'm not convinced
you might ironically win i'll vote for
him yeah i thought that tom cruise
commercial where he was running and he
was like i'm running for something
president i think he might have said i
was like oh is he actually running
because i will vote for him i can't take
it anymore yeah it was just some dumb
commercial but if we get someone to run
i mean talk about you need someone
that's fit to serve like trump's getting
fit do you see that he looks better than
he did he's looking good i'm worried
he's going to get too old by the time it
comes around
i wonder if he's on all that life
extension stuff he's got to be an ad
plus and nicotine my mononucleotide
james garlic says
thomas paine in common sense regarding
parents opposed to war with quote but i
have children essentially calling them
bad parents quote let there be troubles
in my day that my children may know
peace best quote i love that quote i
just think you know
when your kids are in the gulag make
sure they know mandarin that was jack
that was jack bosovic's joke he was like
my job in the prison camp is to teach
people mandarin so that we can interact
with the guards
well there you go
yeah if you if you don't want to stand
up for your way of life or your country
for your values then just start teaching
your kid mandarin and i literally mean
that i'm not being physician like
it's a useful language yeah it's second
most spoken language in the in the
planet and if you are totally down with
the the hegemonic rise of of china then
just be ready to have to interact with
your business even if you're not down
within you just see well that's the way
things are starting to go i'm only one
person can't make that much of a
difference to stop the rise of china and
the rise of biden the rise of the
democratic establishment you know i
remember when i was younger i was always
uh learned spanish
was like one of the things because of
all the
immigrants coming in and you know if
you're working in a kitchen or
now mandarin it's because of business
right so english is the business
language of the world that's why english
is basically everywhere for a lot of
reasons but um
soon mandarin i know a lot of people who
speak mandarin to be completely honest
and i feel like also china is is i feel
like they're the ones that would want to
force the rest of the world to learn
their language because that's like a
power i don't know
they speak english they do they do yeah
we don't speak mandarin but it's gonna
change that's why i'm saying like hey
give your kids a leg up man
oh yeah like the alphabet in writing is
is tough right
all right let's see patriot american
says i'm glad you mentioned directive 51
tim just finished playing both the
division games and watched all the lore
videos it's mind-boggling to me how
similar the situation in the games are
to what we've been seeing this past year
you guys know the division i don't know
the plot uh there's a pandemic
so the president enacts directive 51
you know activating the division a
special elite task force to go and try
and restore you know government
authority or something like that and
then part two is it the first one's in
new york man it's new york it's awesome
running around new york and i know new
york so it's like you're in manhattan
and i'm like i know everything is and
then in dc it's like you're in the white
house and like you're wanting running
through dc and i don't know dc as well i
used to because i played fallout 3 a lot
but still really really fun games like
you can launch drones up and fly around
and stuff and you have gadgets dude it's
a legit fun game yeah game's good good i
haven't played in a while though i
wonder what the new gta is going to be
what i was hoping is that they were
going to map the real world yeah like
they did with the flight simulator i'm
hoping that they just come out like hey
you can just play in the world and then
vr and vr cool
but i feel like there's gonna be a lot
of problems when you're driving cars
into people's houses real houses i
wonder if you'll get people to like
authorize the use of their house in the
in the games
like a one cent per sale uh microsoft
flight simulator you can actually fly
around in a plane of the real world and
maps like a school you have a co-pilot
too it's like multiplayer
i tried to play it it's too difficult
it's not really fun
i got a buddy as a pilot yeah thinking
about jumping in and co-piloting with
them one day yeah
jesus sanchez says tim stargate season
four episode 16 watch it it has to do
with jabs it's on netflix
um i don't know if this is the episode
you're referring to but there's one
episode where
they uh you're most stargate yeah
awesome show by the way it just it's i
watch it on comet and they race they
restart it over it's a bunch of episodes
i missed but um i've seen a ton of the
episodes so far but uh there's one
there's one planet they go to
where there's this advanced network of
planets that they're unfamiliar with the
stargate network which connects all
these different planets through
wormholes but they're extremely advanced
and they have great technology and they
come to this planet that's mostly
agrarian where there's farmers they have
big machines harvesting crops and
dropping them in the stargates to
transport food to their planets and they
talk to this like little farmer guy and
he's like they leave us alone don't
bother us so we're fine
but then they they go into a cave a
couple of them and they discover the
remnants of a civilization akin to
1910's the united states with like
industrial development
that just ceased to exist and they find
newspaper and it's written in like a
form of gaelic because the point of
stargate is that aliens were enslaving
different humans and transporting all
over the universe
yeah and so
basically the plot is
this advanced alien race created
a biological weapon that sterilizes
people and what they did was they say
we'll give you our great technology
oh you have a pandemic a flu pandemic
here this vaccine will save you and it
did but then all of a sudden nobody
could have kids and the entire
civilization collapsed
but there's also um utopia you guys ever
seen that one no yeah they canceled it
because of covet i think oh my gosh it's
about a big tech uh uh mogul
who creates a fake pandemic in order to
sell his vaccine which sterilizes people
because
and this is only how i think it was on
amazon last year it's a show on amazon
and they canceled it i guess because
they were like a little too you know
poorly timed yeah
it was about like the there was a guy
who was writing a comic that predicted a
lot of what was gonna happen because he
had like access or whatever and so
they're like trying to read the comic to
figure out what's gonna happen and i'm
like that's really funny because like in
our world there's a tv show saying all
this stuff is happening and like you're
trying to watch a tv show it's just a tv
show i don't think it's you know real or
whatever but they still canceled it
which just make people more
conspiratorial you know
black mirror
all right
sorta says omg i can't believe you said
that bro keep californians in california
they voted for it they should eat it
that's the thing is there's still how
many million californians out there that
are not voting for that right that want
to be free if you send every single
republican california and properly
disperse them across every single swing
state we would win every single state
except california and new york
all right so
disperse
all right we'll just do one more we got
coldylox production says if my job
follows this mandate i will say no or i
will quit no questions asked
i will not comply
stand up for yourself
you know speak up
peaceful non-compliance
resourceful persuasive all that good
stuff
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're going to start putting together
this members only segment for all y'all
and that'll be available around 11 or so
p.m you can follow the show at tim cast
irl don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you'd like to follow me personally
because i post typically sarcastic
nonsense and troll posts on twitter it's
at timcast and the funniest thing is
i have this this post about how there's
659 000 heart disease deaths every every
year
mostly and people are older than 60 but
it scales down to a decent amount and
i'm like we got to shut everything down
we got it we got to ban unhealthy food
we got to mandate exercise we should
mandate heart medication for everyone
especially children
and boy do these people not understand
life
these you know they're just
you know my the funniest thing was like
when i called howard stern a loser i got
a wave of howard's third fans howard
stern fans telling me that i was poor
and i was just like what i don't
understand why i'm supposed to care like
i called howard stern a loser because i
have a very low opinion of him
and your response is yeah but he's rich
i know that dude's rich it's like when
we're done
our billionaire has more billions than
you're a billionaire yeah i know and i
was just like i'm like that's so weird
that you would like tweet at me like ha
ha you're poor but it's like for one i'm
not
and two what does that have to do with
me calling howard stern a loser like is
there a group of people criticizing him
or joe rogan who know that who think
they're not rich yeah whatever man
anyway timcast.com joey you want to
shout anything out um yeah i guess if
you're on youtube you can check out my
new youtube channel uh the joey saladino
show it's like a conservative news
podcast it's also on all the podcast
apps the joey saladino show you type it
in anywhere you'll find it
cool man uh yeah
fourmediancrossline.net and uh at ian
crosson on social media thanks
i do have to say that i really love
joey's idea of encouraging people to
move out of heavily blue states and into
swing states as someone from colorado
which was red and then became purple and
is now blue because of california i
highly recommend influencing these
states and i think that is a recipe for
success good idea anyway you guys may
follow me on twitter at sourpatchkids as
i attempt to gain more followers than
sarah patch kids we will see all of you
at timcast.com and the members only
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys
you